e
everyone and February 18th meeting of
the science technology and energy
committee we're hearing having public
hearings on five different bills this
morning and this
afternoon and we also are going to have
an executive session this afternoon from
1 to
whenever so we'll start in just a moment
but first I'd ask you all to rise and
join representative Swanson as he leads
the United States of America to the
stands
Nation indivisible with liy and justice
for
all okay so it'll be a busy morning I
suspect and uh so I think we should get
started so I'm going to open a public
hearing on House Bill
692 relative to utility compan companes
adopting Advanced meters and I'm going
to call on the prime sponsor of the
legislation representative McGee to
introduce it to us morning cat uh good
morning Mr chairman and uh good morning
members of science technology and energy
um I'm cat McGee I represent Hillsboro
35 which is Hollis New Hampshire um
excuse my voice I have a little bit of a
cold um HB 692 is an extension of Prior
bills that we've attempted to put in to
uh get a handle on when our technology
will be upgraded and advanced enough for
us to be able to partake in truly
competitive markets so you'll notice on
the first page of the bill the analysis
says that this bill requires the
electric distribution utilities under
the Pu which have not yet implemented or
are not in the process of implementing
interval and advanced meter
functionality to develop a plan to make
such metering available to customers on
an opt-in basis basis the reason it's
designed that way is that in the past uh
you know we've been made aware of the
fact that when all of the meters for any
particular utility are replaced at the
same time there's a significant cost to
that and uh we're not looking to
mandate uh upgrade costs that will uh
impact rate payer bills but we know that
these advancements are coming and we
don't have a plan currently so that we
understand um when we will be done with
uh this migration and when we will
basically have the functionality that is
so needed uh to create those competitive
markets that we keep talking about so uh
in the first section of the bill on page
one section one findings and
purpose it just talks about allowing the
energy markets to to be fulfilled in
terms of their
complexity uh by providing technologies
that will um enable the features that
are needed for us to reconcile what
energy is being used and what value is
appropriate for that
energy um and this part two says uh or
section two says until the utilities
upgrade their infrastructure uh to
enable accurate load settlement
practices we limit meaningful energy
planning sty lowering cost or cost
lowering projects
and prevent um accurate valuation of
distributed assets that prohib that
prohibit us from basically demand
lowering management so there are all
these uh functions that we can't get to
if the technology is inhibiting our
ability to to do that so the idea is
that we want some clarity around uh what
capacities folks are going to be able to
have and when they will be able to have
those um so we're basically asking that
if a utility is not in a position at
this point to offer Advanced
metering uh capabilities which include
um you know interval metering that is
conasur it with what the iso New England
requires or load settlement practices
that um enable additional features for
competitive suppliers then we're asking
them to produce plan so the bill asks
for uh I think a date of November
2026 to provide a plan to the Public
Utilities Commission that will allow us
to know what the timeline is for us
being able to convert remaining meters
the other thing that this bill does that
and I've spoken with um eversource I
provided them with a copy of the bill a
couple of months ago and we've had a
conversation in between there seems to
be a little bit of uh conten between the
folks who are really anxious for us to
have this capability which is basically
the competitive suppliers um who who
need um this level of granularity in
order to function the way they would
like to with pricing
signals um and the utilities in terms of
whether as the utilities are replacing
meters that come up for replacement each
year um whether they can replace those
meters with Advanced meters so they
don't have to to replace them all at one
time that is their practice generally
especially at eversource which is the
largest um utility
provider um they normally replace them
all at the same time but because they
are uh replacing at least a handful of
meters in the in the few thousands maybe
five or 6 thousand a year um this bill
asks that they come up with a plan to
allow those meters to become Advanced
meters as we go um and that it would be
the option of the
individual um to opt into having that
meter and they would pay for any
difference in the cost of replacing it
with an um an older meter that doesn't
have the advanced capabilities uh they
would play that pay that difference so
that it's not shifted onto other rate
payers so the bill tries to answer a lot
of the gaps in us trying to move towards
technologies that would be useful to the
competitive market and and um I know
there are folks who will be able to
speak to the specifics on the utilities
part and also from the perspective of
the um you know Community power
aggregators so I think that's probably
all I need to say in um in introduction
of the bill and if anybody has any
questions I'll try to answer them thank
you for that introduction we appreciate
that and thank you for bringing this
bill forward so I have a question
shouldn't this be covered by the
integrated
distribution resource planning that we
uh asked the utilities to do a couple
years
ago um that's a good question and I
don't think we specified that but
certainly I would think as a planner
myself if we were doing integrated
planning that that should be a component
of it maybe the utilities can answer
specifically uh whether there is such a
plan already and whether this is a
component of it I don't know I think
passing this bill would ensure that it
would be part of the planning which is
what I'm hoping to
do okay further questions for
Harrington thank you thank you for
taking my question um just a a couple of
quick things uh you mentioned that this
would be done as meters needed to
replace so we're looking at a small very
small amount of meters because some
people that will get replacement meters
will say I don't want to pay extra for a
interval meter because I don't even know
what it does
um so we're looking at how many years
before you would see a significant
impact on the amount of meters out there
it sounds like would take for a very
long time that's true um I I think that
the that eversource has a plan to
replace all meters with AMI and we're
we're in a queue um because they service
other states besides New Hampshire and I
think we're the last to have the
replacement which which is projected in
about five years so
um Connecticut and Massachusetts I think
are ahead of us uh for full replacement
to to get to get to that better
technology um and you're correct that in
that interim period in the interim five
years you'd have a handful of meters
each year I guess the idea was at the
way the plan works now is those meters
would not be replaced
with uh with smarter meters I guess is
the quick way to an Ami meter they not
planned to be replaced with improved
meter because the um utility doesn't
currently have a backend that supports
them they do drive by meter readings and
they would have to change that practice
all at once my understanding is that if
you adopt an Ami meter you can um it can
be supported through uh a Wi-Fi you know
a cloud-based app in the interim and the
utilities would have to modify in order
to accept the data that's being placed
in that cloud uh as the way that they
would get information from that meter so
they would have to adopt a new practice
but they wouldn't have to change all of
their back end at least that's my
rudimentary understanding and there are
people that can speak to the technology
itself followup follow up now course
we're talking about interval meters but
there I don't see any mention of time of
day rates I mean if you have an interval
meter and it tells you how much power
I'm using at at 11:00 and 11:05 and 1110
and so forth if the rate is the same 247
of what benefit is that to me yeah um my
understanding is it's not I mean there
are uh people there are already
customers in the region on the grid who
are doing interval metering and the
whole point is to get us to actual uh
rates and to understand uh what we have
for rates and also be able to leverage
those rates in order to create savings
so um we've talked about that before
that people plug in at a time when you
know the the the rates are lower at home
and and they um can also Place energy
back onto the system at a time when you
would have you know higher demand which
generally drives up the rate in order to
sort of lower um you know the overall
curve follow up but but it's to be clear
in this bill does doesn't do any of that
there's no time of rate time of day
rates okay well having an Ami meter
means that you would be capable of doing
that right you have the capability and
what we don't have right now is the
technical capability and we're trying to
see how we can uh more rapidly move
towards having the technical capability
to to support the kinds of energy
transactions that allow us to understand
correct price signals um and ways to
lower demand when we need
to I'm sorry about my voice very
scratchy representative bney has a
question thank you chairman and thank
you representative M for taking my
question um I thought it was interesting
you said that uh they could upgrade the
Ami meters without any backend upgrades
um it doesn't say that explicitly
anywhere in the bill but um I guess the
question I would have is uh on the
second page on line two it says uh with
such meters and utilizing subscription
based meter data management system um
yes so somewhere and then all the way at
the end uh lines 23 to 25 are saying
that anything that isn't covered by the
customer opting in is going to be um you
know covered by the rest of the rate
payers so um is that am my
misunderstanding that the bill actually
says that there is some backend
upgrading that would need to be done or
um I guess that's my question yeah I
mean I think what this this refers to as
any Delta that's incurred by the utility
right so if the utility has to provide
access to a subscription service or if
they're um acquiring data on the back
end through a subscription service in
the interim before all of the machines
are replaced which will be you know a
reasonable cost that they will recover
so at the time that they replace them
all they'll have this large amount to
recover but in the interim I think what
this section 23 I mean letter line 23
and 24 in section two on on page to is
referring to is any prudent prudently
incurred cost to implement those
Advanced meters in the interim so it
would be again a small cost because it's
a small number of meters but they might
have to they might have to um use a
subscription service themselves in order
to be the recipients of data that they
might need from those meters in the
interim because it would be not
collected through driveby meter
collections does that make
sense followup
um okay thank you that sort of explained
a little bit but um my my thinking is
that by allowing any of the cost to be
um recovered and then saying that there
has to be a subscription based uh data
management patform when you talk to the
utilities did any of them say that um if
they offer this it would be them
offering the the uh subscription based
meter data I I just can't imagine a
utility selling the data or or having
somebody else manage their own meters I
guess that's the part I'm not really
understanding yeah I me that's a good
question and I think they they can
answer it better than I can in terms of
the details on it my understanding is
that folks who have Ami meters Now by
choice or folks who are part of the
system with other providers than
eversource which is they're the they're
the long poll in the tent they're the
last of the utilities that's in line to
adopt this technology across all of
their customers so um the other folks
that are already uh involved have the
option to use their meters with a
web-based service subscription and the
subscriptions are inexpensive so it's
not like it's a it's not a huge cost
that would be you wouldn't feel it
across 540,000 customers so especially
if it's 5,000 meters a year right so
it's a very small cost but I think the
bill just tries to be as thorough as
possible in explaining how costs would
be allocated
so that it's fair and that it's in
keeping with our existing
practices does that help representative
bernardy uh has a question but before I
recognize him I'd alert anybody who
wants to testify on this bill but you
need to fill out a p card and pass it my
way thank you representative Bernardi
thank you chairman so if I understood
what you
said uh eversource is the last uh
utility to come in into the program of
having uh or establishing a program for
these Ami meters they have a plan to do
it in five years why do we need to put
this into a bill if they already have a
plan to do it in five years yeah thank
you for the question and it's it's a
good question it's why would we need to
intercede well we know there's a plan um
and the plan is basically holding up
several other
aspects of the competitive market at
this point so I think we would like to
understand the plan we would like to
ensure that by November of 2026 there is
a plan and that that plan includes what
will happen in the
interim um so that we are moving forward
as quickly as we can right follow
up so do we need legislation to do that
or can we just ask ever source to
provide this committee there their
plan um well their plan is to wait for
the five years and do it all at once
which is how they normally do their
migrations um and so the issue really is
do we see technology and the components
of technology and the meter is a big
piece of that as something um that we
should have some say over in terms of
being able to enable this functionality
sooner we have competitors in our Market
who are trying to provide Supply
services that are um dependent on
technology and right now our technology
is um is not sufficient so the question
is what do we do uh do we do anything
and and this Bill is saying we should
try and do uh something to work to to
incentivize uh the utilities to give us
a plan that says what's going to happen
between now and that 5 years they don't
don't normally do anything within the 5
years they they want it to be a clean
sweep um and my understanding is
that the technology allows them
to um to provide smarter meters in the
interim as their replacing meters and
we're just suggesting that that might be
a good idea and if it has to be
supported by a non-standard process but
it still can work in order to provide
that data now then we think that we
should be moving towards that so I think
it's a question of having having the
utilities disprove this Theory right and
say we can't do that it doesn't work and
I've had the conversation um with Mr LCA
that that's not the way they operate and
their and their current backend systems
aren't going to read these more advanced
meters at this point but my
understanding is from uh from the
competitive market that there is a
capability
for them to use a cloud-based service in
order to allow both the customer and the
utilities access um and there's and
privacy concerns are you know obviously
protected by the service but this
subscription is available so that
individual meters could be fed into um
the utilities
question thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my
question and I if I own an electric car
which is basically a big battery on
Wheels and if I could charge my car
during periods of low demand and low
price and then turn around and provide
electricity to the Grid at high demand
and high price would I not benefit uh
and make money actually and also would
that not benefit the grid and its
customers by doing load leveling by
shaving the peak load to the grid and
the customers thank you you don't have
to answer that because it's not about
the bill it's not okay it it's not it's
not directly about the bill it's
transactive energy right it's another
sophisticated energy thing we could be
doing if we had better technology so
that's the only way it is related to the
bill representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh representative McGee for bringing
this bill uh this is kind of related to
representative Harrington's question
about time of use um
this bill allows the utilities it seems
like to to recoup some of the cost of
installing these meters which would be
an incentive to install more of these
meters because that would be an
infrastructure cost that they could then
you know add onto their distribution or
transmission costs um so would it not be
then in their interest to also provide
time of used tariffs fairly soon after
they implemented this plan in order to
incentivize more people more customers
to to have these smart
meters well I don't think I can speak
for them um I I think that this is
um that the bill is trying to
acknowledge all of the players in the
system in terms of trying to advance the
idea that the sooner we can adopt the
technology the sooner we will be able to
move towards lowering demand and and
um and assisting people with figure out
ways to lower their costs right they'll
have that capability they'll have
granular information about that but the
section that says the commission shall
ensure timely cost recovery for utility
cost prudently incurred to implement and
integrate the advanced meter optin
option it's a very very small part of
their cost and they're already allowed
th this is just really um rearticulating
the language that already exists I mean
the utilities whenever they make a
prudent investment they're able to
recover that from the rate payers so uh
what we're trying to do is really
incentivize a conversion to the more
sophisticated technology more rapidly
system okay seeing no more questions I
want to thank you representative for
introducing this legislation we'll call
on next Matt Young from the New
morning so for the record my name is
Matt Young I'm an attorney with the New
Hampshire Department of energy um the
department is neutral on this bill but
did have a few concerns just wanted to
raise here uh this morning um so first
the department does understand that it
would be very expensive um and maybe
come some a an AP word uh to implement
Ami metering functionality from
a uh data Gathering and uh Billing
System perspective of the
utility
um so I think even if those Ami meters
were put in the functionality uh may not
necessarily be there for uh for some
time and then in a similar vein uh this
bill is introduced uh seems to
contemplate um I I guess a a permissive
cost recovery from those customers that
opt in um but there was just some
concern of cost shifting uh with the
language of this bill um and something
for the community to consider is whether
uh um those customers that do opt in
should should be the ones um paying for
the
upgrades and then finally the um last
thing I just wanted to mention uh at the
outset was I guess more of a structural
um structural con concern with this
language was um it was the Departments
understanding that the intent of the
legislature with the creation of the
department uh was to have it implements
um what I guess I'll call the policy
implications um or policy um
implementations excuse me and then the
uh the Pu would then kind of turn those
policies into a rate um so something
such as this
um the the I guess policy is sort of
directs the commission to to direct the
utilities to do certain things um and
the department feels that that might be
better suited with with the department
and I think to sort of illustrate that
example um or to illustrate that is an
example of Dees uh the Department of
Environmental
Services uh permits the alteration of
land for utilities and those rates are
then recovered um in uh through the Pu
in a rate case the the commission does
not have any um does not have any
involvement in the alteration of land
permits or anything like that that that
falls squarely on Dees and then the
commission turns that into a raid so
that's just sort of um illustrates kind
of the example that um just wanted to
kind of put out there for the committee
um and with that happy to answer any
questions well thank you appreciate that
if I understand or understood what you
just said on line 27 of the page one of
the
bill there is text that says the
commission shall direct such utilities
to develop a plan are you saying that
that should be the department that
directs the utility to De develop a plan
sure and um and that could that could
come in the form of you know by rule by
order um similar language like
that thank you further questions for Mr
Young representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um and thank you for being
here um can you tell me what the
department of Energy's position on
timing of adoption for Amis or smart
meters is so there is the uh integrated
resource plan which is um supposed to
come out I believe five years after the
bill became effective um the department
is setting the schedule for that um I do
believe that that'll come out
shortly thank
you representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you uh for
coming in today um you mentioned that
you had some or the department had some
concerns about cost shifting I I I just
wonder if you could uh just go into a
little more detail about what that would
entail because it seems like the the
bill does includ some language for the
utilities to recoup the the cost of
imple of implementing the the change
over
so where does the cost Shift come in
sure um so from the Department thank you
for the question U from the Department's
perspective the language of the bill
does include um you know uh I believe
it's page two um line 19 states that the
rate design um and skipping ahead may
include Provisions for charging the
customers requesting such meters um I
think that language could be read uh to
be almost permissive in nature so it
wouldn't necessarily have to go just to
those opting into the um I guess program
I'll call it um and there could be some
concern that individuals not receiving
costs thank you representative
Harrington has a question yeah referring
to page one uh the bottom on lines uh 25
through
29 I'm trying to determine exactly what
this says but it seems to be talking
about uh having by November 1st
2026 uh interval and advanced metering
functionality capable of reporting
hourly consumption or exports to the
grid of all and most of their
distribution customers for use and load
settlements so is this going to be some
type of time of you excuse me time of
you settlement what what how do you
interpret that what that going to what's
statement so I probably take that
question back and and talk to some
people at the department on how we would
necessarily interpret that I know that
um a lot of the load settlement issues
and things time of use are um actually
coming up in bills this morning uh but
are also parts of ongoing dockets as
well um and they're
just complicated subjects I guess so I
would have to take that back and see how
we would interpret that and quick
followup quick followup yeah I was just
looking at the iso New England uh report
of lmps and would you agree that time of
use isn't everything that it's not the
Panacea that some people say because I'm
just looking and the price in the last
12 hours has varied from around $100 a
megawatt hour to over 300 back down back
up back down back up so unless someone
was sitting there watching it I don't
not sure how much great how much value
this would
be I think I could say there's certainly
fluctuations in the market um and how
those are captured I guess is a question
decided Representatives Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you for being here
um at the outset you
mentioned first question you did say
that this would be very expensive right
that's the Department's understanding
yes followup
followup the way that I'm gathered ing
this is that it's just asking utilities
for a
plan about doing something that they
would end up being doing anyway so
somebody would have to foot the bill
ultimately or this would these are
things that would never be implemented
if we didn't have direction to do
it so back to the the question is
wouldn't they be doing this anyway and
it I I I think I would direct that
question to the utilities on on how they
would operate thank
you all right seeing no further
questions no you can't ask a question
don't you're not supposed to sorry all
right thank you Mr Young we'll move
along and I'll ask the honorable Chris
Clifton Belo to come and talk to us to
give the CP cnh perspective on this
legislation good morning Mr Belo nice to
again you turn on the mic please sorry
uh back in 2005 uh the Congress passed
the energy Policy Act of 2005 um which
set forth a number of policies that they
asked uh state legislatures to consider
adopting and one of those was Advanced
metering functionality and time-based
rates
and the Pu undertook an investigation
and then in judic proceeding to to
consider that at the time um eversource
had old mechanical meters that you had
to walk up to to read so they had a
large Workforce of people would go to
every month and read the Meers
essentially manually um and um the the
commission concluded at that time that
we should uh move towards Ami uh and
essentially directed the utilities and
the staff to um uh consider in a future
proceeding um exactly how to do that and
when to do that um around 2014
eversource decided just to install AMR
meters which is just when you Dr you can
drive by and collect the data but it
didn't have the advanced uh
functionality of Ami um and and so those
meters have about a 20-year life and
they're being uh depreciated over 18
years um so uh
in their last um docket uh for a
distribution rate case um this was an
issue as to whether it had been prudent
of them to invest in the AMR instead of
the Ami that the commission had said
they should should consider um and as
part of that uh uh case um there was a
settlement uh in which um eversource
agreed uh to evaluate um this
possibility of um Ami
and specifically uh the settlement
called for uh them to consider uh doing
this both on a full replacement or a
partial opend meter deplacement uh uh
replacement and uh considering using
existing Telecom networks for um uh
opt-in option um and so they did do a uh
feasibility study but it did not look at
the option of doing this incrementally
it just sort of was an All or Nothing
proposal and they they looked at a
couple scenarios what's the fastest we
could do it and what's a more optimal
time frame for doing it the fastest uh
would have um Ami uh starting uh this
year uh you know basically in terms of
planning uh and uh completing by 2028
this was sort of suboptimal uh because
they still have a whole bunch of meters
that they haven't depreciated that are
on their books so they said an optimized
scenario would be to wait until we're
reaching the end of the life so
um around 2033 in about 8 years is when
they'd actually be putting uh Ami in
place um uh to uh with the intent to
replace all these 20 year old meters uh
by 2034 and a couple years thereafter so
that that's a little bit more than five
years out that's more like seven eight
nine years out um the cost of that um
they estimated up around $400 million
and it's and because the approach they
would use is What's called the itron Gen
5 Network which is a complete buildout
of a mesh network with a communication
system in which and they're started this
in Massachusetts and they're moving
across the state and building out this
mesh network with replacing all meters
and building in a whole new
communication system and a whole lot of
other Investments that's where it gets
to4 m00 million in the last um
distribution rate I'm sorry the last net
metering case in
2016 um I intervened on behalf of the
city of Lebanon and and we proposed uh
that there' be a time time a pilot of
time of use uh uh time varying rates uh
for net metering um that customers could
both buy and sell at uh real-time prices
for instance and um Liberty agreed to
collaborate with us on that and the Pu
um said yeah this would be cool to do
this time-based net metering rate um
which you both buy and sell at at these
uh real-time prices and um so we
collaborated with Liberty and we put out
a joint request for information to see
if there's a way because they don't have
Ami to put in interval meters uh at a at
a small volume like a 100 or 200
interval meters itron responded and said
yes we can do that we have a solution
for that which is a complete soft uh
software as a service cloud-based uh
data collection system it can work with
cellular meters and we can do it
incrementally and it's a subscription
you only have to pay per meter so we
asked oh well how much might this cost
because we wanted to get an idea of what
it would cost to integrate into their
existing Billing System and subscribed
to the software and they said well
interesting you should ask normally we
would not give that information out
because it's kind of competitively
sensitive but they said the town of
middle uh burrow Massachusetts has just
recently posted has selected itron to
convert all their electric and gas
meters to Ami and they posted on their
website it our complete proposal so it's
publicly available so I went at the
suggestion of the itron sales
represented and downloaded what is
marked as a confidential and proprietary
document um we you know ever source is
saying we take hundreds of millions of
dollars this is at the most in the
hundreds of thousands actually tens of
thousands and it shows exactly what the
software is a service which they say is
a comprehensive so the utility doesn't
even have to add personnel or make any
investment uh to take advantage of this
there is an integration with billing
systems but they've said they you know
they've done that a lot over a lot of
systems and and they point out it could
take 10 weeks not years to implement
this solution the cost for the
cloud-based service per meter $3 a year
on a 5-year contract um for fair fairly
small number of meters so that is what
this bill contemplates trying to enable
and to seriously consider um uh you know
I can probably probably stop there I I
would just point out that um they do um
eversource does invest in buy a certain
number of new meters every year in 2023
the test year for their distribution
rate case they bought uh almost 13,000
meters uh 8,000 of which were actually
deployed otherwise their study said they
also said about 1% a year they almost
have 600,000 meters so 5 6,000 meters a
year is what they're purchasing
purchased today they have a 20-year life
18-year depreciation if they convert in
2033 or 2035 you've still got half the
depreciation on that what was for 2023 a
$35 million investment so you we
potentially end up with millions of
dollars in stranded cost when they do
finally convert to Ami say in in the mid
2030s um so this is a way to avoid that
uh potential loss of value and I believe
they actually pointed this out in
Massachusetts and said maybe we should
start putting the kind of meters that
will be compatible with what we're
planning in the future instead of buying
more Legacy metors that are going to be
uh uh not fully depreciated when when we
convert over and we'll have some
stranded cost so that that's sort of the
motivation here uh the idea doing this
incrementally came from the Pu staff out
of the grid modernization investigation
and said why not do it this way and my
final point is this set a light bulb off
in Liberty's mind which they said oh we
could actually do a three-part time of
use rate which ISO New England actually
recommended back in the early 2000s that
that the state should move towards uh
for their battery pilot and they now
offer it for uh EV charging um and uh
opening it up to some other uses and
they're doing it with these cellular
meters that they at a fairly low cost
integrated into their existing Billing
System um and in terms so we're the
community power Coalition is very
interested in offering our customers
these expanded rate options like large
commercial users have because they have
interval metering and when you have
interval metering you can actually
settle the load based on the load shape
and so if you help the customer improve
their load shape or shave their Peak you
can actually realize that value for the
customer and this is what we're trying
to bring uh and expand and not be in a
situation when they get to convert and
they say well now we have a bunch of
replacement meters that we haven't
depreciated so somebody's got to pay for
that thank you okay thank you for your
testimony questions for Mr Belo
representative Bary thank you chairman
and thank you for taking my question um
so I don't know very much about these uh
the the technologies that are in some of
these Ami meters but you mentioned that
um eversource is rolling out meters with
a mesh Network yes and I'm assuming
Massachusetts that's not the same thing
as a a regular cellular meter and so my
question would be um those are different
kinds of meters or at least if they have
a planed to roll out mesh Network meters
and we're saying go ahead and do
cellular meters then those cellular
meters wouldn't work on the mesh Network
so no no that the the itron uh
specifically says they have meters uh
that are designed specifically for this
purpose so that you can start with them
with more like with a cellular system
and then convert to the mesh Network and
they have that option built right into
the meter you can just switch once you
deploy your mesh Network you can take
the cellular little card out of it if
you want to and have the uh RF radio
frequency one that talks to other meters
they have meters that are designed to be
forward compatible uh to uh this kind of
system that ever source is going to in
massachusett so just follow up yes
follow up so the these meters are these
are the meters that they're rolling out
in in Massachusetts that work like that
or is this a different kind of meter
that you're talking about no they're
using R they're doing the mesh Network
ones and and they're geographically
saturating the conversion because the
meters they rely on the meters talking
to each other
um the the
yes related to that though is is the
cost question the cost is not
necessarily that high with cellular we
we asked in a discovery if they had
considered this approach and they
basically said no because cellular costs
more than a mesh Network well that would
be true for um half a million meters um
but if you're dealing with a few
thousand and you're having the customer
or their supplier pay for the cellular
service um then it can be done uh at a
fairly low cost and and just to
illustrate that the city has uh over 700
street lights with a communicating meter
uh this two-way directional reports
every hour the data and the data service
for those per meter are 40 bucks for 10
years so that's four bucks a year for
data service um and includes an extended
warranty on the control node itself uh
for that 10-year
period okay thank you I have a question
about the bill itself on page two if you
I'm curious to know why does the bill
require that the priority for these
meters be given to limited producers and
customer
generators over everyone
else that would seem to favor deers and
aggregators over everybody else is that
the intent here or what exactly is the
purpose of that those lines the the
Commission in the current net metering
proceeding has expressed a strong
interest in uh
trying to create time varying options in
conjunction with net metering uh so that
right now net metering basically says
all kilowatt hours are equal in value
and that's not really true there you
know the price changes every hour day
ahead every five minutes real time and
um uh so you know part of the issue I
mean that doesn't probably need to be
there but the idea is that these are
potentially uh uh systems that Import
and Export um with customer generators
or limited producers and uh that seems
to be a place at least from the
commission and I I would say also the
doe the Doe's major recommendation in
the current net metering docket was that
we need to move to time of use rates or
three-part time of use rates for net
metering instead of saying all kilowatt
hours are equal in
value okay thank you additional
questions representative Harrington
thank you thank you for taken my
question so let me see if I've got this
just the nutshell version of this it
seems what you're saying is a couple of
things one we continually replace meters
as they need to be replaced because they
get old two eventually in I guess five
years we're going to be going to a
system that uh will have advanced
metering and time of use metering
installed so we're starting now or with
the enaction of this bill we should
start replacing meters with the advanced
meters because in 5 years we're going to
have to replace them again if we don't
is that the nutshell of the bill uh yes
except except I think in their optimal
scenario it's more like eight years and
and and there's no commitment to that
quite yet okay all right thank you
additional questions representative
Kaplan thank you thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr Bel for coming in um I'm
interested in the difference between the
cost estimation for the replacement that
uh that the uh utilities came up with in
that docket that you mentioned versus
the uh
uh you know what you're talking about
the cloud-based service and how much
that's going to cost so there seems to
be a difference there and uh so that
brings me to my question about the cost
shifting concern that the department of
energy raised how would you respond to
that cost shifting concern given the
lower implementation cost that you're
describing um
what I mean to do the mesh Network
approach um
you know their own uh estimates uh the
AMA the Ami Network and communication
that's like $200 million the other 200
million is for other it upgrades and
other uh new systems to take advantage
of some of the
functionality none of that really needs
to be incurred uh to do this sort of
itron cloud-based option
um they there it would be a cost to
integrate the data into um either their
their customer Billing System and and uh
load settlement system uh but they
already have the means to do that with
interval data for the large customers
so yeah there would be a cost there but
itron at least in their Middleboro Mass
proposal says they've done this all over
the world um and with this and they do
it particularly for small utilities like
Municipal Utilities or Co-op that may
only have uh 5 or 10,000 customers and
can't afford to make a big investment so
they they they say well let's we we can
do most of that work for you we can help
you integrate it and we're experienced
with that so let's explore that
possibility followup so so you mentioned
that there might still be a minimal cost
shifting uh would you agree that that
would be outweighed by uh the benefit of
opening up the market to to more
competition that this would allow um I I
think that's highly likely and and
there's going to be you know if they
keep investing in Legacy meters up until
the time that they convert there's also
going to be a bunch of cost shifting
probably from them to rate payers for
useful representative partiel has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for being here today Mr Bel uh by
reducing um the peak load I'm going back
to a question that was asked earlier on
page two line four
um by reducing Peak load it will benefit
all
consumers and so uh what putting the uh
availability of time of use meters into
the hands of those who can most
effectively impact that have a benefit
to all
consumers um well well yes I I I think
that um the idea of having the supplier
of the customer pay the incremental cost
for the more expensive meter and then
pay for uh the subscriptions service to
support that um the customers or their
suppliers only going to want to do that
if they think they can produce value
which might be just ways of helping
control flexible demand that are
automated like uh outside of the areas
that have gas in New Hampshire there are
a lot of storage hot water heaters and
they sto they store so you can there's
inexpensive devices uh that you can use
to control them so that they store up
heat for the peak after late afternoon
early evening hours and and you can help
shave the peak that way uh and so it and
around the world many many use uh
applications have been found and and
they're very it's helped support a
flexible load Market that's able to um
help shave those high price periods and
Peaks and and produce sort of value for
everyone thank
you okay seeing no further questions I
want to thank you Mr below for being
here and give the last word on this
legislation to Michael Lata of
eversource and any of the documents I've
have I'd be happy to share I just didn't
want to burden you with a lot of paper
today thank you we appreciate that
Lata good morning uh Michael Lata
representing eversource energy
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you today also appreciate
um the bill sponsors intent with this
legislation and her focus on um
progressing technological advantage
advances and grid modernization uh we've
had a number of conversations uh uh and
uh certainly we I understand uh where
she's coming from and her goals uh
however um we are opposed to the
legislation um before you today um I I
think there seems to be a little
oversimplification of an Ami uh Network
and the different components of that and
what is required to enable functionality
uh the meter itself obviously is very
important component but is just one
component of an overall meter system uh
Ami Network system uh first you have the
meter you have the communications
Network that uh Mr buo talked about you
then have to have a collection Point uh
known as a headend or a meter data
management system to collect those large
large volumes of data so compared to uh
the uh system that we have in place
today where you're doing sort of monthly
Drive buys interrogating the meter
downloading the data um here you're
talking about a much much much larger
volume of of information and then
perhaps most important importantly and
critically you then need a customer
information system and a billing system
that can accept that information those
large volumes of information interpret
it and actually be able to generate
customer bills based upon that um as has
been discussed uh as part of a
settlement in our 2019 rate case
eversource hired a third party uh West
Monroe uh to do a what was termed an AMF
Ami uh feasibility study uh what it
really was is a cost benefit analysis of
the cost of of various scenarios of
installation of the entire uh structure
that I I spoke about and the benefits of
it and what that study found was uh the
planning and timing of this uh roll out
is is very very important uh costs to
customers ranged from $400 $73 million
to $394 million benefits ranged from
$364 million to $315 million so a lot of
variability as you can see extremely
large numbers uh this is is not
inexpensive and again one of the reasons
for that is eversource currently uh in
New Hampshire has a number of of older
Legacy
systems uh they function well they
accurately take customer information we
accurately build customer information
but virtually all of those systems would
require replacement uh and in the future
will require replacement as they reach
end of life in order to enable Advanced
meter functionality and so that is why
you see the large price tag associated
with the am uh Ami conversion so simply
having an Ami meter Simply Having a
cellular network does not enable uh the
current structure that we have the
current billing systems to accurately uh
generate customer bills uh that is is
just an unfortunately an incorrect
statement that our current systems could
accommodate that uh and each utility has
their own systems each utility is uh in
a different place with with converion
other utilities have been mentioned here
uh some of them have recently gone
through customer information and Billing
System conversions to newer uh more more
current uh applications uh eversource in
New Hampshire simply is not not in that
place today and one of the reasons uh
and this was discussed in our Ray case
we did not push ahead uh is because of
of the necessity to optimize for the
benefit of our customers to reduce costs
as well as a recognition that customers
with very large storms that we've
incurred uh inflationary pressures are
uh facing significant cost increases
through our rate case so we try to be
sensitive to not overloading uh our
customers with with costs um I would
note uh eversource in Connecticut does
not have Ami metering uh we have
submitted uh plans and information to uh
uh the their version of the Public
Utilities Commission uh those have not
been approved uh we only within the past
uh year or two got approval in
Massachusetts and that was part again as
a multi-year conversion changing out
back office systems changing out billing
systems building out that mesh Network
so uh unfortunately what the bill would
propose on an optin basis is it would
require the utility to essentially uh
offer me ERS that would not have have
really the basic functionality that we
need in order to to Bill our customers
accurately and it certainly would not
enable the advanced functionality that
Ami meters uh allow
for with that uh I'd be happy to answer
questions that I can well thank you we
appreciate your perspective on the bill
uh I have one quick question for
you in order
to recover costs in a prudent
manner wouldn't it be a utility business
decision on how to do this metering to
ensure that prudency issues were
addressed
adequately absolutely uh and that is
part of the um Ami feasibility study
that was completed that I mentioned is
to look at what is an optimized scenario
to reduce cost again we have a number of
systems we have meters that will be
approaching end of life uh over the next
several years and how do we properly how
do we uh intelligently replace those
systems deploy new newer technology for
the benefits of customers but do it in a
way that is is low cost otherwise the
chair is absolutely correct we run the
risk of uh essentially being found to to
have operated imprudently and run the
risk of disallowances there just one
other thing I I did want to mention
because it had been discussed and I
apologize I didn't bring up earlier um
there's been a lot of conversation about
time of use rates time of day rates uh
reducing Peak usage I I I would just
inform the committee eversource today
does offer time of day rates we offer on
Peak and off peak pricing uh other
utilities some have Ami meters some have
AMR meters offer similar uh similar
programs some offer in New Hampshire
some offer on Peak off peak some offer
critical Peak mid peak and off peak so
all the utilities and certainly cannot
speak for any of the others do offer a
form of of time of day piece Peak
reduction pricing that is available to
customers
today I have a follow-up question we
heard it mentioned earlier that stranded
costs are a concern about the plan that
you have in place currently is that a
legitimate concern are you worried about
stranded
costs absolutely I I I think we're
always cognizant of uh incurring costs
that that then are no longer in use um
and as we develop plans for the
deployment of of Ami metering in the
future it had been mentioned that in
Massachusetts as we were further along
in the back off office conversions we
did look at the the earlier deployment
of some meters as part of the normal
replacement process but again as we sit
here today we would be deploying meters
given what we have on our our back uh
back end that would simply not have
functionality we we simply can't even if
it has a a cellular communication our
systems can't uh process that
information in render
bills representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Lata for coming in
uh there you mentioned the feasibility
study uh and that was to replace the
entire network uh and I'm assuming that
also included the Billing System yep um
is it possible that a partial
replacement of the metering and could be
accompanied by a partial replacement of
a billing system so that you could then
use so that you know they the these new
meters would have some function ality is
is is that not possible to have a
partial uh substitution of your Billing
System with a cloud-based system
unfortunately it it is not
essentially we we have a Billing System
uh we actually have two billing systems
one for large customers one for uh
smaller customers and you can't sort of
go halfway uh you know you you need a A
system that works it works for customers
um and so that system would you know you
can't sort of replace part of it to
enable the functionality given the the
age of
it representative Harrington has a
question yeah I'm just trying to get
this straight on the meters now um are
you saying that if if it's part of your
routine replacement with meters if you
put in Ami meters under your existing
Billing System they wouldn't work I mean
I know they won't give time of day
because we don't have time of day rates
uh but could it still function as the
meter does now and get someone a a bill
at the end of the month my understanding
in talking to our back office teams is
that the volume of data could not our
current systems could not handle that
followup follow up no I'm not talking
about handling the potential output of
an Ami meter but could the Ami meter
simply function like the historical
meter does now and you know someone go
by drive by the car and do whatever they
do and get a reading how many kilowatt
was used that month and send you a bill
does it because it contain that
functionality such that it would work
your existing system I'll have to check
on whether an Ami meter could be
programmed to essentially function as an
AMR meter all right thank
you representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Lata you mentioned Connecticut uh is
ever Source uh supporting Ami meters in
any other place
uh so we operate in three states New
Hampshire Massachusetts and in
Connecticut in Massachusetts as I uh
said we are in the process of deploying
Ami meters that was part of a multi-year
conversion in Connecticut we have filed
a plan that has not been approved and so
we are not advancing at this time follow
up follow up so that means that then the
backin systems are either in place or
going to be in place in
Massachusetts why can't that be ported
to New Hampshire so each each state uh
as it exists now has its own unique
Billing System uh ultimately our our
longer term goal is to have all three
states operating on a a single system uh
obviously that would have tremendous uh
efficiencies uh for for our uh staff uh
but again it it has to be done in a uh
stepped uh planned
process representative bery has a
question thank you chairman and thank
you uh for taking my question so there
were uh two different time frames given
uh one was 5 years that you guys were
going to roll something out another one
was seven years can you speak to that
and also my I guess a follow-up question
to that would be um on page one
um
see oh no I guess yeah just that that
question sure I I I think the two
different time frames are when we would
begin some of the back office system
conversion uh Replacements and then when
we would actually uh deploy the meters
and and be able to utilize that
functionality followup follow up and I I
just thought of my second question my
second one was on on page one on line 25
it says um uh utilities are not in the
process of implementing uh these would
you guys consider yourselves in the
process or not in the process of
implementing it thank you I I I think
that's a fair question I I think we are
not currently in the process of of
implementing we are certainly planning
exploring and and developing plans but
we are I I think it's fair to say that
implementing Vice chair Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question Ju Just My Own
clarification you mentioned about the
other two states that you operate in but
in New Hampshire's case
we had Public Service New Hampshire and
they probably had their own system at
the time that it was you know the time
you took it over is that one of the main
reasons why we're on a different system
than than uh the other states that's
correct each each state had its had its
own legacy customer information billing
systems uh and that's not uncommon uh
that you know each utility would sort of
have in the past sort of a homegrown
system um now as technology has advanced
there's sort of third parties that offer
these systems they're kind of
standardized and that's where you've
seen a number of of Utilities in New
Hampshire and and uh in other states
have gone to these kind of third-party
platforms uh which obviously offer uh
efficiencies but you're absolutely
correct Vice
chair representative Ros has a question
thank you Mr
chairman um and thanks uh Mike for being
here again again and answering questions
um earlier last fall and and now this
spring I've built at my house a a new
detached two-car garage with an
apartment over an Adu and I just had a
the new meter installed on that building
two weeks ago so I got a new meter which
I've learned through testimony tonight
today is I guess going to have some
stranded costs associated with it when
it becomes
um unusable later on I'm I just wonder
isn't there the possibility that
eversource there could be some value in
learning by doing uh in replacing say
the 5 to 6,000 meters per year that
we've heard about that ever Source buys
new meters and installs each year
couldn't the utility learn by doing by
allowing inst know supporting
installation of advanced metering and
then
yeah learning to support them rather
than having to do it on a massive scale
in in five years uh
so all of the limitations and challenges
that I talked about are are real uh and
and confront us that said um we do I
completely agree in the value of
learning by doing and creating
efficiencies uh and so one of the
benefits of one of our sister States uh
sister utilities down in Massachusetts
going first is that we can learn from
their experience and try to avoid
pitfalls that they've encountered and
you know if there are areas that they
were able to move faster than they
expected we have the value of that
knowledge uh in terms of when we do
Implement in New
Hampshire okay thank you we appreciate
your testimony and seeing that's the
last pink card we have on House Bill 692
will close the public hearing and will
immediately open a public hearing on
House Bill
755 and I'll call Representative cat
McGee to the front to um introduce this
legislation
good morning Mr chair and members of the
committee nice to see you all again for
our next our next round um you'll notice
that all of the bills today uh are
similar in that they are being put forth
to try and address the competition in
the market that we've been trying to to
enable for quite some time now so um
I'll just get started again I'm Kat
McGee Hillsboro 35
Hollis um on st& we have some things we
agree on we seem to agree on free
markets and
competition and finding ways to lower
costs in fact free market competition is
the best way to drive costs
down so what is necessary to support a
free
market a Level Playing Field Innovative
entrepreneurs and accurate price signals
these are the ingredients that create
fertile ground for free
markets many of our new members may
think New Hampshire is not really a
leader on energy policy saying we should
seed Innovation to other states as
though it's a good thing to ignore New
Hampshire's innovators and opportunities
that we have here in the state to unlock
the competition that drives cost down in
fact New Hampshire was the first in the
region to deregulate the utility
Monopoly in 1996 to enable competitive
suppliers to begin building a truly
competitive market it was
purposeful but the coalitions and
collaborations needed to get policies
passed to get to that competitive market
are hard one we often say that energy is
complicated and it
is we have harder a harder and harder
time explaining what is a good what is
good about a bill uh or good about this
bill versus that bill
but we have to try and understand when a
bill that appears complex is actually
part of a solution for enabling
competition and helping to bring costs
down each year those entrepreneurs who
are often industry experts provide us
with ideas for legislation to do what we
say we want to do enable the competitive
market to bring cost down and that is
what HB 755 is designed to do in section
one the legislative findings and purpose
section it does an excellent job of
explaining some of the problems uh
passing this bill would work to
resolve suppliers who compete with
utilities cannot offer their customers
accurate value for net metered net
metered energy because Energy prices
change throughout the day if the actual
price of the energy you use is never
properly reconciled somebody is winning
and somebody is losing a Level Playing
Field would be if we could use actual
time of use rat for actual energy used
so the value earned and the value to the
grid is appropriately
placed section two starting on page uh
two line 25 modifies a definition for
grid modernization and in section three
there's a definition for load reducer uh
which is also added for
clarification section four begins on
line 15 and talks about retail Market
reforms and that takes up the remainder
of the six pages of this bill which I
will let the experts behind me speak to
in detail but finally there's a fiscal
note on the bill I wanted to draw your
attention to um that says that this bill
would require upgrades or Replacements
of some Utility Systems including load
settlement systems and customer
information systems in order to fulfill
the pro the provisions of the
bill the estimated expenditures for
these upgrades are deemed to be in the
millions of dollars it doesn't say how
many millions just apparently a
lot these systems upgrades are already
being required um by Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission order
2222 uh in an order that was passed in
2020 to remove barriers preventing
distributed energy resources from
competing on a Level Playing Field as
participants in the electric grid of the
future so as you can see from the amount
of ground that I've covered talking
about this bill there are number of
impediments that are facing us right now
in terms of modernizing our grid and
enabling competition in a way that
actually benefits the rate payers of New
Hampshire and there are many different
uh entities at the federal level at the
regional grid level trying to enable
these pieces and the legislature has a
role to to play if our grid requires
functionality that our utilities do not
yet support then they need
legislation uh like this to incentivize
them to answer the question of when we
can expect this hold up to retail price
signaling to be
resolved if grid systems operators are
requiring minimum standards for
transactions on their systems that
support time of use rates and load
settlement then the utilities will be
charging rate payers for those upgrades
whether we pass the bill or not because
they're going to be forced to provide
that functionality
this bill helps our statutes reflect
where we are at in terms of the energy
markets in the state of New Hampshire
the Investments uh to make modern energy
markets work are something that we
should view as essential to providing a
means to Spur innovation in the state of
New Hampshire and to provide the
competition that lowers rates and costs
and that's that's my testimony
thanks thank you very much
representative for introducing this
legislation do we have questions
representative bernardy has
one thank you chair uh
so you said this this going to be
extremely costly I think if you're going
if if you're going to uh
understand the the benefits you have to
be able to quantify them I ask you to
quantify them rather than just
generically say we're going to have you
know benefits from this against the cost
that's what we have to really assess so
can you provide an adequate cost benefit
assessment of this activity
now thank you for the question
representative Bernardi um the bill
itself uh doesn't entertain to provide a
cost benefit analysis and what it does
though is it tries to um provide a way
forward to enable competitive markets
which is where we believe savings will
be right if competitors are jockeying
for position in a market to provide
service that allow people to save money
they're going to be competing with each
other and that competition is going to
help drive cost down we don't currently
have a fully competitive market and that
has a lot to do with the fact that we
are not uh enabling that Level Playing
Field that allows everybody to see the
value of the data um use the data in a
way that would be helpful to lowering
our demand and so what we're trying to
do is say these things need to be AED
and the fact is getting to the point
where that functionality is enabled
through the
utilities is something that we're not
we're not the only body that's vectoring
towards that right the federal
government is saying you need to make
this competition available you need to
level the playing field you need to
allow people who are trying to create
energy close to where it's being used to
get on the grid and help support um
creating greater grid stability which is
another desire that we talk talk about a
lot and also being able to compete in
that energy Supply Market in a real way
so that's that's really the point of the
bill and as I said the costs of that we
can't get away from those costs because
at some point we have to do it what
we're saying is is it better for us to
try and enable that sooner so that we
can realize cost savings sooner and know
what we're doing rather than just leave
it to
chance follow up
so if I understand you correctly there
is no cost benefit an analysis now and
you say you you just indicated that what
we need is a Time based cost benefit
assessment no I think that all of the um
experts and Regulators that manage and
maintain our very complex Energy Systems
and grid have already decided for
example this order under the Trump
administration of uh furk 2222 it says
you need to do this right and because it
has the benefit of supporting an
advanced grid grid res resiliency and
reliability and uh also a a distributed
system
so I think the growing pains that are
coming from this are that we have a top-
down system that we're trying
to force to allow a bottomup system and
the bottomup piece is the distributed
generators and they need to be
accommodated by the former Monopoly
system uh in order to allow for the
system to grow in a way that makes sense
we have Regulators saying this has to
happen right and then we have our piece
which is how do we make that happen and
uh there are people who can speak far
more eloquently than I can I just sort
of have big picture perspective on this
but what this bill is seeking to do is
just remove some of the um impediments
that currently exist in our system that
will allow the competition to come I
can't give you a cost benefit analysis
for what competition would do in the
system I only know that competition
always does the same thing if it's
enabled on a Level Playing Field then it
will it will drive the cost down because
it will provide better and better
products and people will choose those
products and and it will drive the cost
down of services so that's my story and
I'm sticking to
it okay representative Harrington has a
question thank you thank you for taking
my question I'm I'm looking on uh page
three where talks is is a definition of
a load reducer and the first one is it's
has a maximum rated export capacity
point of inter connection uh less than 5
megawatts is not registered as a
generator and a doesn't participate in
any other F jurisdictional markets by
that I assume you mean the energy and
capacity markets but what I'm trying to
get a handle on this is if there was a
let's just say a 4 megawatt a 3 megawatt
a 2 megawatt another 4 megawatt whatever
they don't have any obligation to serve
right they can provide this load
reducing service when it benefits them
and when it doesn't benefit them for
whatever reason or because they can't do
it they have no obligation like a normal
registered generator would to provide uh
Power or or someone who's a demand
response uh registered under the uh
capacity Market uh has an obligation to
provide that demand response these load
reducers would be great if they work
when we need them but if they're not
available there's no penalty to them is
that
correct thank you for the question uh
that is probably above my pay grade to
answer you specifically I mean I
followed everything you said but I don't
know that I know the answer so I won't
pretend to um I did want to alert folks
that on line 8 uh there is a typo that
needs to be corrected uh and that is
that the term atrr stands for
alternative technology regulation
resource um and I my assumption is that
if you're operating as a load reducer on
the system that you will be you know
identified and available and
um and recompensed for the value that
you bring to the system but I don't know
the specific answer to your question so
I think somebody behind me can probably
answer it
better representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you represent McGee once again for
um I I'm just wondering whether you
would agree with me that this sounds
kind of like deju this this argument
about cost benefit analysis didn't we
undergo this same debate when we talked
about the Grid modernization bill that
we passed and uh secondly um well no
I'll just leave it that would you agree
that that the cost benefit analysis has
been St in statute when we set when we
passed that Grid modernization bill and
this is just trying to cement the the
the market transformation that that
previous Bill uh
envisioned yeah it's a good point um I I
think we are continually trying to
answer questions that are held up by the
fact that we don't have adequate
insights and Technology available um to
necessarily drive us to exact answers uh
so it's a chicken and egg in terms of do
we do something to try and incentivize
us to get to that place um or do we
continually hold up in a energy Market
that's moving forward without us with
advancements that we could be helping to
push along and um so the grid
modernization uh piece is just a small
piece um uh the value of distributed
energy piece and the net metering piece
also all feature into this how do we
integrate new systems in and value them
properly and make sure that everybody
that's contributing is able to benefit
from the value of what they're bringing
to this new grid um and at this point we
haven't solved for those things
and we have to be able to see some of
these bills for the part that they play
uh in getting us to a Level Playing
Field in in in including the ingredients
again that I referred to at the
beginning in my testimony that will
actually allow us to have a fertile
competitive market which we don't have
right
now okay thank you seeing no more
McGee before we move on then let's uh
let's have a little chat about the rest
of the morning it's
now 10:25 we need to break at
11:45 in order to uh have a caucus for
the Republican members before
lunch I've got six people who want to
testify on this
bill and then we have three people who
want to testify on the next bill so
unless you want to carry this these P
morning public hearings over until the
afternoon then I suggest we accelerate
our uh question and answer period for
the people who are testifying on the
this this bill and the next bill I'll
thank you I appreciate that all right
next up is Matt Young from the
good morning again Mr chairman members
of the committee uh for the record Matt
Young I'm an attorney at the New
Hampshire Department of energy the
department is neutral on this bill and I
just wanted to um raise a couple
concerns and I I think emphasize a few
things um the first is that um there is
I guess there's sort of a lot to absorb
in this legislation um kind of a lot to
take in and I just wanted to highlight
that many of the the um Provisions in
this bill and issues are part of several
dockets before the Pu right now that the
department is a part of um and I just
wanted to highlight that there has been
quite a bit of time and I guess with
that a cost associated with
participating in those dockets
um so if uh the legislature does I guess
decide to proceed um on this I would I
would point you to those dockets and um
there's Reams and reams of of
information um that has been proved
provided by the parties and those
dockets um so I I would urge you to
review that um before moving forward and
I think the second sort of similar
similar point is that um and I I I
believe a previous speaker this morning
sort of mentioned Discovery um so with
that I think what what comes with um
sort of the the vetting process of these
pu proceedings is just a a thoroughness
to those answers um those answers are
answered under Pains of penalty and
perjury um so they they're just sort of
a
um thoroughness and um kind of a fact
check that goes into that uh sort of
naturally um next um I just wanted to
raise
that while this legislation does seem to
uh attempt to address issues that are in
those dockets um I guess first it's not
clear that uh all the parties in those
dockets are here today um I'm aware that
several of them are but I think I would
just note that some some parties may not
be as legislatively focused so there
maybe something to consider as well and
I don't know that the legislation
necessarily addresses um some of the
cost shifting concerns that the
department would have uh with with it
with uh this legislation
um it it was briefly discussed by the
representative earlier um but I think
there's still sort of a question of uh
costs um finally I think I just wanted
to note having um been present for other
legislation uh this session um that
there is sort of a conversation I think
happening um around restructuring and
moving a moving away moving towards kind
of what's what's happening there and
there's
um I I think several bills kind of Go in
different directions so I would just
kind of urge the committee to take that
into consideration as well um moving
forward and with that happy to answer
any questions w for the doe
representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman then me
take my question with reference to page
three um this uh starting on line
18 it talks about pursuant to relevant
ISO tariffs and goes on so forth and so
on uh will take effect in November 1st
2026 is there anything in those tariffs
that the iso is um putting into effect
on November 26 that would require this
bill to be passed in order to be in
compliance with it the department is not
aware of um any changes of current law
that would be required to comply with FK
order 222
[Music]
um as as implemented by ISO rules
questions representative
schneller brief question thank you
chairman Vose um and thank you Mr Young
for taking my question uh you mentioned
concerns about cost shifting if you
could just flush that out a little bit
that would be helpful thank you so I
think this um legislation deals mostly
with the ability of suppliers um to
offer various um net metering programs
and
if default service provider or default
service customers or customers who
aren't part of those um supplier
programs or customers of those buyers if
they'd be
um if it would be their respon if it
should be their responsibility to pay
for those costs to allow the the
suppliers to offer the the um prices
that they would
like does that answer your
question yes thank
you further questions representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
Mr Young um I have a problem trying to
understand the cost shifting of of
implementing this
legislation as opposed to the the
lowering of cost to the entire uh user
base that would come with incentivizing
distributed generation resources for
example can you describe I mean there's
been discussion here about cost benefit
I mean has the department constantly
raises this issue of cost shifting has
the department done a cost benefit
analysis
so as I mentioned these are um ongoing
issues in dockets and I can't speak to
the exactly what's what's gone back and
forth in those dockets but that would be
precisely an issue that's discussed in
those dockets I don't have that
information in front of me but those
cost Ben benefit analysis conversations
are are are being discussed
there follow up I'm just yeah thank you
for your answer I'm just curious I mean
you have access to those dockets can you
not
summarize the findings for us here at
this public hearing it seems that that
would be
helpful so the the department does have
that information I can't speak to that
today but you will attempt to satisfy
representative kaplan's question sure
I'd be happy to to follow up after this
hearing okay seeing no further questions
we'll move along and I'll ask Alex om
from Unitil to give us a utility
back good morning thank you for having
me uh for the record my name is Alec Oma
I am here representing Unitil and we are
uh in opposition to this bill we oppose
it uh first one this session I believe
we have opposed um when I go through my
process uh internally on finding out how
we feel about a specific issue I usually
reach out to a variety of different
departments within the company uh any
that might be particularly touched by
that particular issue and I get answers
and that's generally how I sort of start
working on How I build out uh how we're
going to talk about a particular issue
with this particular bill um we I ran
into a bit of a problem because each of
the Departments I spoke with emphasized
a different piece of this uh particular
legislation that they took issue with um
many of those issues have already been
discussed today um when I talked to our
billing folks they talked a little bit
to me about the uh costs that would be
associated with the integration I think
eversource talked a little bit about
that during the Ami Bill uh how simply
installing Ami and installing the
Technologies and implementations that
would be required to create these load
settlement uh solutions would have great
cost um I think that the fiscal note
used the term Millions uh that's an
off-the-cuff term I think that our
billing folks generally agreed with I
don't have a precise number but
generally when talking about integration
with customer information Services it is
a costly Endeavor for sure uh when I
talk to our supply folks uh they talked
they they questioned the premise of how
much ultimate savings something like
this may ultimately generate for
participants regarding load settlement
um and you know it was more of a
conceptual conversation but they
acknowledged that folks that are
receiving uh that have net metering
right now are seeing benefits from that
program uh the costs associated with the
uh integration that would be required um
for the granual level of information
that would be required would you
ultimately see substantial savings uh
it's a real question that they had um I
know that's going to continue to get
discussed at the Public Utilities
Commission which not for nothing was one
of the points that our legal team had
that there was so many pieces of this
that are already getting reviewed within
the Public Utilities Commission like the
department of energy said that really
require that detail and it's it's the
proper forum for a lot of these
conversations because this is a very
complicated and very complex concept and
the time and the detail and the care and
the vetting that will happen at the
Public Utilities Commission is really
the appropriate place for a lot of this
and then finally our regulatory team
also knowledge the cost shifting issue
that's already been brought up uh we
have net metering customers that already
benefit from a degree of cost shifting
uh opening up another potential front on
cost shifting with this particular
concept would lead to a host of
additional challenges we recognize
that's already a controversial issue
within the state uh in regards to
existing net metering this simply would
potentially create another Avenue for
those types of uh conversations to occur
um in short Unitil believes in using the
distribution system as an enabling
platform for Innovative Technologies I
think we've demonstrated that in a
variety of different areas but on this
particular concept we're not there yet
and that's the message I wanted to
convey to you folks
today excellent thank you we appreciate
the utility perspective and that gives
me an opportunity to ask you a question
about one of the issues that has
concerned me about this bill and that is
following utilities traditionally
recover their costs through energy sales
kilowatt hour
sales so will widespread load reduction
as this
bill seeks to uh make happen will that
impact utility revenue models and if so
how much well I don't have a number in
terms of what that would be I think
that's part of what would potentially be
discussed within the public U ilities
commission but I think ultimately what
you're getting at is the the concept of
cost shifting that ultimately gets
talked about with these types of issues
if you see a net reduction in one area
for one subset of customers the
potential then would exist for those
costs that would then need to be
recovered to be recovered across other
customers that aren't necessarily seeing
that specific savings when people talk
about cost shifting that's often the
concept that they are trying to get at
and that leads to the concern that we
see here where there might be costs
associated with this program that would
be incurred by all customers whereas the
benefit would be seen by a
subsection okay thank you representative
Corman has a question thank you thank
you Mr chairman thank you Mr Amir see
you um as I understand it Unitil already
offers time abuse rates uh and if
so why do you need to make changes to
the Billing System well we do have time
of use rates um the concept here as I
understand it is uh above and beyond the
current existing time of use rates and
also includes a number of other
integration aspects uh specifically with
the the real-time Concepts that have
also been discussed here uh we do have
Ami uh that Ami is was installed in the
mid 2000s so is reaching end of life
right now um anytime we're integrating
into our existing customer information
systems there's a ton of
uh it's I've seen a couple different
upgrades to our CIS system over the
years and it's a Time intensive uh
difficult process that involves making
sure that these systems can talk to a
variety of other softwares in a really
uh complex way that requires reliability
of
information okay additional questions
representative
Harrington yeah thank you thank you
check my question I'm I'm looking at
page three of the bill and again it it
talks about a load reducer and it says
uh less than five megawatts well what we
would Now call Net metering we only
allow a maximum of one megawatt except
for
municipals does this then get around
that by simply calling what could now be
classified as net metering load reduces
and allow them to go up to almost 5
megaw um I'm not entirely sure to be
perfectly honest I'm not as technically
Savvy on that particular topic I can
find an answer for you on that one I can
talk with our folks and get back to you
follow up followup and my my previous
question I don't know if you're able to
answer this one but it appears that
these load reducers with a value of what
does it say export capacity of up to 5
megawatts would have no obligation to
provide anything unlike if they were to
be uh demand response and bid into the
uh wholesale capacity Market where they
have an obligation to deliver demand
response these resources at least it
appears would be able to deliver the up
to five or slightly less than 5
megawatts when it was the weather was
good when it worked for them when their
equipment was running right but if
something happened they'd have no
penalty or obligation to not pro to
provide that service is that
correct I believe what you're getting at
is the concept difference between a net
metering customer and a full-on
generating facility is is kind of where
you're driving at I believe how you're
articulating that is correct um I I
think that the point I'm trying to make
here overall though is that the concept
as a whole we're just not entirely sure
that the that it's going to create the
benefits that are
articulated additional
questions seeing none we'll move along
and call next on Dean Dennis and Clifton
good morning
morning
okay good morning chairman Vose and
members of the committee um for the
record I'm Dena Dennis director of
regulatory and legislative affairs with
the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire and here with me today is uh
Clifton below chair of the Coalition
board
um just as a refresher the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire or cpcn
is a community govern powered Supply
agency serving 50 Community power
programs across the state um and 200,000
customers since we launched service
nearly two years ago we've helped
customers save more than $20 million on
their energy bills the community power
Coalition supports House Bill
755 uh New Hampshire's energy forward
act because it will enable True Market
competition for Innovative Services by
leveraging local distributed energy in
New Hampshire and by distributed energy
I'm referring to small scale power
generation and energy storage facilities
that are under 5
megawatts
um uh also uh demand response um
customer own generation electric
vehicles um and other uh customer
customer techn Oles that can flexibly
shift electricity usage to off peak and
lower uh cost times encouraging Co the
cost effective development of
distributed energy will lower our energy
costs increase customer choice and local
control strengthen grid reliability and
Community resiliency and move New
Hampshire's energy economy
forward the reason that cbcn is
proposing the reforms in this bill to
have more explicit requirements for how
innovation in the retail Market Market
um such as Innovative rates and value
added services to customers as permitted
is because right now and as uh
representative McGee alluded to entities
like the community power Coalition and
other competitive suppliers are not able
to provide these
Innovations um it's been the policy of
the general court since 1996 to develop
competitive markets that achieve lower
costs for electricity customers despite
this most residential and small
commercial customers to today can only
choose flat rate commodity service
options from Community power programs
and competitive suppliers value added
services such as time varying rates and
programs to enable distributed energy
remain unavailable in practice while
utilities alone can offer these
Innovations the lack of a market
emerging to offer these kind of
Innovations is largely due to uh
utilities not keeping up toate their
software systems data access and
business processes that are essential to
enabling um Market competition this
limits customer choice and prevents
competitive entities from introducing
new products and investing private
Capital to build out distributed energy
where it makes Financial stents to do so
the energy forward act requires the
necessary changes to utility managed
retail Market facilities including data
access metering billing transmission
pricing and load settlement systems to
enable True Market
competition with these improvements
Community power and competitive
suppliers across the state would be able
to offer innovative solutions to
customers on a voluntary basis without
these improvements the state will
continue to rely on state regulated
utility programs for net metering
customer de or distributed energy
programs and utility-owned distributed
generation projects and rate payers will
continue to ultimately shoulder the
costs when utilities recover those
Capital expenses
regardless of whether the Investments
actually deliver on the benefits
projected in contrast the New Hampshire
energy forward act enables
permissionless Innovation so that
suppliers and developers can contract
for the construction of new local energy
projects offer new Innovative services
without waiting for utilities or going
through lengthy pu proceedings to
dictate the pace and extent of
innovation these new market-driven
distributed energy and customer programs
would be paced paid based on actual
performance that is by how much
wholesale energy capacity and
transmission costs they reduce and not
through administratively set rates and
rebates determined by state Regulators
with automatic recovery of costs and
guaranteed profits for utilities as
representative McGee pointed out the New
Hampshire energy forward Act is well
timed because the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission has been trying to
expand market access for distributed
energy to participate in wholesale
markets um including uh the iso New
England markets um the new requirements
automatically apply to eversource um
because of eversource's size um
including that the utility that
utilities like eversource permit
competitive entities to self-pride um
interval metering for distributed energy
and that's needed because you need
accurate um and more frequent
measurements of what the de what the
distributed energy is is doing what
they're using and what they're producing
onto the grid um and that eversource and
other Utilities in New England um their
load settlements need to start to
accurately track those outputs and
allocate load impacts to individual
suppliers um and the energy forward act
elects that the same Market enabling
reforms should also be implemented for
New Hampshire's other utilities Unitil
Liberty and New Hampshire Electric Co-op
I think all of them are sitting behind
me right now um and this Bill calls for
joint implementation of many of these
reforms across all four New Hampshire
utilities by Contracting with a single
expert vendor to perform load settlement
calculations and leverages the
opportunity to modernize load settlement
on a Statewide basis if it's more cost
competitive and to enable competitive
Innovations and Achieve cost
efficiencies while it's been raised
whether the Public Utilities Commission
is addressing these matters the answer
is sort of um well Community power
Coalition has been advancing key
proposals at the commission not all of
these reforms are being considered in
the scope of active proceedings at
present um and we believe legislative
action is necessary to enable a
competitive retail Market um so while
these changes to Utility Systems do cost
money the investments in mostly software
and business process changes are
necessary to enable an order of
magnitude greater investment of private
capital capital into distributed energy
and cost-saving Innovations for
customers and as previously mentioned
the largest utility in New Hampshire
will already need to invest in these new
settlement and Data Systems to comply
with the federal Rules by November 1st
2026 um so in summary if we want to move
to a more competitive market and Empower
customers to have maximum freedom and
choice over their energy options we need
the reforms contained in House Bill 755
otherwise utilities will continue to
dominate in this space and there will
fewer options for customers and fewer
ways to reduce costs thank you for your
time and
questions questions for the folks from
the community power Coalition
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um there's been a lot of talk
about cost shifting um can you tell me
what the VD report says uh regarding
cough shift shifting specifically with
do you want to tackle that
um I I've read that report
um but I don't recall that it actually
addresses cost shifting per se um it did
conclude in
general
um that the value of distributed energy
resources is uh close to their current
level of compensation I I'll just leave
it at that it's fairly uh complex but
the general conclusion was um our our
general our level of
compensation generally uh aligns with
the benefits that that are realized
thank
you additional questions representative
Harrington yeah I'll follow up with the
question I asked to the gentleman from
the uh Department of energy uh and what
he told me was that he would the
department was not aware of any Law
changes needed to comply with the FK
order is implemented by ISO New England
and it sounds like you don't agree with
that could you uh follow up on that
please um yes
um I I think that's more or less true
for eversource uh because eversource is
of a size that they are uh subject to
these requirements which are uh
scheduled to be in place by November of
2026 as
November a year from now at which point
they will either need to provide uh uh
this this uh you know essentially ISO
New England specified metering
requirements for aggregated distributed
energy resources these These are um for
order 2022 is about aggregating small
deers um uh so that they're of a size
that they can participate in the iso New
England Market in which case they would
be if they bid into capacity they would
be subject to the Capac capity
requirements of a market participant
that that whole framework um does not
extend to the other three Utilities in
New Hampshire and essentially
um the the what fur approved was that
generators um I mean distribution uh
utilities that distribute 4 million
megawatt hours or less uh in the
previous fiscal year don't have to do
this until unless the the term is
relevant regulator electric retail
regulatory authority meaning I guess the
Pu although that Authority uh is vested
in the state constitution in the
legislature and then it delegates it to
the puc and doe uh but it it it it the
state has to permit customers of the
other three utilities to be able to
participate um as aggregated uh
resources in the iso New England market
so that would need
uh I think some legislative direction if
if if you're serious about wanting to
create Market options uh based options
um to to drive prudent you know
decisions about use of resources uh then
um some action would probably be needed
to indicate at least that the Comm pu
has the authority uh to require this if
they find it's in the public interest I
mean this bill would just go ahead and
say this should apply to all the
utilities thank you
so following up on that question from
representative
Harrington is it possible since we've
been trying to develop competitive
markets since
1996 which is like 29 years is it
possible that competitive
markets are
incompatible with a utility regime that
requires that there be regulation of
utilities there there is no free market
for the utilities so you know how can we
expect there to be free market for other
things um well I think that's actually
been pretty well thought through around
much of the world
um the the the Monopoly function of the
distribution utilties is to distribute
the power it's the poles and wires and
all the infrastructure that supports
that and that supports a competitive
market um and I think that was
understood at the outset of
restructuring um and and what we've seen
is uh in in many places um very robust
competitive generation markets where
investment decisions and power supply
are are in the private sector and so if
they if they don't forecast correctly
rate payers aren't risk of that bad
potentially bad investment so
I I don't believe that competitive
markets for power supply and for demand
response services are at all
incompatible with a monopoly function
for distribution services and it a
little bit goes to the question of well
isn't this going to mean lost revenue
for the utilities not necessarily
because if a storage resource or a
generation resource is putting power
onto the distribution grid they still P
pay charge for Distributing that power
um so there's no uh sort of harm there
what could happen is if DRS are
responding to to price signals that are
temporal in nature that they're going to
help shave these Peaks which potentially
means when you shave the Peaks and can
shift load off of the peak into less
Peak periods um it means for for the
capacity the whole system um because the
whole system generation distribution
transmission has to be designed to meet
Peak capacity Plus a safety margin um so
to the extent we have Financial signals
or Market signals that Peak is expensive
which we do with the capacity uh you
know it's based on the single hour of
highest peak demand in New England then
what we're going to see is a shifting of
load that fills more in The Valleys
which means we're spreading all these
fixed costs over more kilowatt hours
rather than fewer because when customers
don't have any access or deers for that
matter people are investing in net
metered resources don't care when they
produce cuz all kilow hours are treated
the same in contrast when Unitil looked
at this and said if we treat this as a
load reducer and pay attention to the
actual price signals LMP capacity
transmission which is essentially a
capacity charge um then what we get is a
different investment um which is a
single AIS tracker and the reason they
said even though that costs more and
it's going to cost more to operate it
produces much more value because it
produces more when prices are high and
demand is High um at least throughout
the summer um and it can produce more in
the winter because it can shed snow and
and follow the sun to some extent so so
the point is you get more optimal
investment when these resources are
exposed to market price signals than
than when they're just being traded on a
regulatory basis and in the case of un's
single access tracker they projected net
benefits uh for customers in the system
but if those net benefits are not
realized customers will still be on the
hook to pay for that investment
eversource in their case distribution
rate cases said we think we'll be
proposing about five of these projects
over the next a few years in the same
manner that Unitil has as a load reducer
where it produces the most value and
this is simply saying let's piggy back
onto fur
um uh which came out under commissioner
Neil Chatter's leadership at FK a trump
appointee a former uh Chief of Staff to
uh leader McConnell um he was one of the
people Help drive this uh effort to open
up uh competitive markets for smaller
distributed energy resources recognizing
that there's potentially a immense
amount of value that and they can get
built quickly we're going to have grown
Demand with AI and all that deers can be
deployed much more quickly than large
new central power
plants representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question we're still in
this world where uh at least for
Community power customers and maybe
third party um canet meter does this
bill move the ball toward net metering
for Community power and and third party
yes would very much it would it would
open up that net metering
doesn't have to be at the utility where
you can get the most value it could be
and and and this can help reduce cost
shifting because if competitive
suppliers and Community power
aggregations can contract with these
resources then there won't be anything
that has to be paid out by the utility
uh to compensate them so this is trying
to create to to move net metering or the
development of deers out of a high
regulated um essentially Monopoly type
Market additional questions
representative Kaplan thank you Mr chair
and thank you for coming in again for
this bill
um would you agree or would you say that
what this bill is intended to do is to
use Market forces uh in other words the
benefits that distributed resources
provide and are currently being
privatized and held on to internalized
by the accounting systems of the
utilities what you're trying to do is
just liberate those forces put them onto
the market to
incentivize growth in the use of
distributed generation resources which
as you mentioned are sorely needed in in
the future because we're going to need
more and more Generations so we should
use an all above strategy and all you're
saying is let's use those Market forces
that right now are just it's inside the
black box of the utility and they're
holding on to them uh let's see what
they are and let's use them to drive
more growth in in in in resources right
and and just using those Market signals
uh to drive more prudent more optimal
use of resources and and Investments and
Investments that Ray payers are not at
risk of if they don't prove
out okay seeing no more questions we
thank you for that testimony and next on
again
on thank you uh chairman Vose members of
the committee um it's nice to be back
again in a bigger room we used to meet
in half this space with the same number
of people in it
representative Thomas is not said I'm
gonna not speak to my uh prepared
remarks because I want to try and keep
this short uh to your benefit but um I
want to speak to an area where I have
some expertise um and that's in it
systems so um I'm a simple guy and I
like to think of trying to get to
complicate things as simple as possible
and I think about you power delivery I
think about what this committee did um
real
leadership um and shman V is right it's
been almost 40 years now since in 96 the
um this committee freed up um and made
you know a competitive market of of
power generation seeing no sense in
regulating it so when you sort of think
about the bolds that that make up the
power delivery system we had one end of
the spectrum we have the generation the
other end of the spectrum we have the
people consuming assuming that
generation and major player in the
middle that's regulated are the
utilities um there is as you have heard
and will have heard many years in a row
I'm sure lots of ideas about how things
could be more Innovative more
competitive more cost effective if there
was more competition between those two
elements of the spectrum and invariably
the reasons that come back frequently
with poorly
documented um cases is it's just going
to be too expensive to do that and it's
usually the utilities they're saying
that today it's also the department of
of
energy um so one of the things I did uh
in my career was Implement large it
systems um Enterprise level systems I
worked um LED for a while the conversion
of the entire University system of New
Hampshire to a modern system and I can
tell you that what I'm hearing today are
people representing
technologies that existed back way
before that shortly after we were
storing memory on cores anyone knows
what a core memory is your memory is
pretty good um it's pre silicone so it's
just if you think about if you were a
Fortune 500 company or you know maybe
even a mom and pop on the street today
this is the 21st century we expect
information when we want it and we
expect to be able to get it in the palm
of our hands most of the time there is
no reason why a competitive industry
should not be able to deliver
information and whatever quantity is
needed by whatever the demand is out
there that bears it and the cost should
be
minimal the advances in information
development systems is such that most
companies 200 utility companies in the
United States alone currently use third
parties to provide their Enterprise
systems at all levels whatever the the
need is and the reason for that is
because they can far more rapidly
respond to demands they have far more
resources they have scale and they have
the technologies that you know a company
whose business is not technology have so
um that's it just makes sense so what
I'm hearing is an industry that is not
really using modern systems for modern
needs
so I to me this tells me two things
there's a resistance to change a because
it suits them just fine to stay where
they are um they are controlling some of
the resources by resistance to change
and it works to their business Advantage
perceived I don't think it's working to
the customer's advantage and the other
reason um that I think that this happens
is who Bears the cost of doing these
changes these are public corporations
owned by investors
if fundamental business processes are
not being
maintained who should pay for that
should it be rate payers or should it be
the
shareholders and I you know the it's a
complicated question it's a question
that a Public Utilities Commission would
have to weigh in on and I think you know
what I would encourage you to do is be
bold as you were you know in 96
open up which this bill does this
bill handles all those little incomplete
pieces of the
law that rectify the situation and allow
the Freedom of Information to flow back
and forth between customers and
producers and that's essentially what
you're getting out of this Bill thank
you very
much well thank you appreciate you being
here and giving us your perspective good
to see you again uh you did mention as
you spoke that you had experience in it
systems during your working career yep
wondering electric companies offer
Billing Services
right
and the changes in this
bill might not support uh no long there
systems May no longer support the
changes that that are envisioned by this
bill so who would pay for those upgrades
and how much would it
cost uh thank you for that question
representative Vose chairman Vose um so
that I think there's some contention
about that I mean one of the things that
you can look at um we're talking about
companies that en large not all the
utilities in the state are you know
owning proprietary systems that they
built in house else some have moved to
third party systems um some are in the
process of doing that and I you know
everything that we talked about today
could be handled by a service it doesn't
have to be you know uh a system inhouse
there are services that will provide
this billing is one of those services
and some of these Integrated Systems can
provide that and the question is
you're here's the fundamental question
technology that dates back you know to
the last century and some parts of what
I heard today sound like they dated back
to the early parts of the you know per
the creation of Technology it technology
and its very infancy punch card
technology um who owns the
responsibility of porting that
technology to where it is appropriate
for today's use I think you know
shareholders have some responsibility in
that to maintain their companies so that
they're truly competitive the problem is
because they're
regulated they have been able to avoid
that
but it is it is a competitive space it
um you know should be should be more
competitive thank you representative
Corman has a question for you thank you
Mr chairman and uh I want to follow on
to Chairman Vose question uh I've
actually been in computer science for
over 50 years and I taught software
design although I'm probably a little
rusty these
days can you talk about the elements of
a billing system that would possibly
costs
well I there's it's a that's a big
question thank you uh for the question
representative Corman uh
um if you break down any
system if there is change what you need
is a system that is agile and robust for
change and I think that's what you're
talking about in all this the change is
going to be
required it sounds like and I don't have
intimate knowledge of specific system of
these utilities but it sounds like their
systems are not Pro
agile if you went to a major vendor and
take sap for example it's one of the
world's largest software vendors for
making Enterprise
systems they have specific systems for
utilities which include billing
systems they are able to produce these
systems not only you know to fit
particular State needs they they adapt
their systems
internationally so the the ability to
change you know requirements in one
environment to another is going to be a
lot less burdensome than if some you
know inhouse Computing group is going to
have to do that work and bring forward U
what may be a really Antiquated system
so um that's where I'm getting at the
cost who should have borne that cost and
making the systems agile and robust and
flexible to meet the 21st century needs
expense all right seeing no more
questions I want to thank you Bill for
being here nice to see you
again next up is Jeremy Clark
Co-op oh he just stepped out all right
um here he comes okay
welcome Mr
Clark thank you chairman Vose I'm going
to try to be brief because I know time
is of the essence and I have a parking
meter I'm worried
about so my name is Jeremy Clark I'm the
financial planning analysis and race
manager for New Hampshire Electric
Cooperative and I'm here today to
testify an opposition to HP 755 on
behalf of the Cooperative we do
appreciate some of the objectives of the
legislation and share some of those
however we do we do have some concerns
about the impacts um as already
discussed there are a lot of concerns
about cost and we know that uh the bill
concedes that it would cost you or the
uh language uh Supply the testimony here
says it would cost millions of dollars
to implement for the co-op alone it
would cost millions of dollars to
implement these upgrades to our metering
load sett settlement billing and
customer service systems all of which
we've borne by our
members um also I think probably of
interest is uh number two based upon our
recent experience in trying to create a
similar hourly pricing program it's not
clear that this kind of system can
actually work uh over the last few years
we attempted to create a transactive
energy rate um only to see it fail
because we could not accurately build
members um the goals of the te were kind
of similar Dynamic pricing so we had a
hourly rate fluctuating throughout the
day uh based upon grid conditions and
allowing members to optimize their
energy usage by consuming more during
lowcost periods and reducing their
consumption when prices were high we
also had the de integration as part of
this uh allowing uh participants with
home batteries or electric vehicles to
grid um to be able to you know
participate when uh to charge when uh
prices were low and then discharge when
prices were high to get that benefit and
also provide members control to have the
ability to manage their own use uh and
to be able to make informed decisions
about their consumption now despite
numerous attempts we could not get our
Billing System to work as intended uh
nor could we adequately align hourly
price signal forecasts with the actual
results um we also realized that there
were far fewer members who were
interested in this uh than we originally
thought or had the capability to
actually take advantage of this
technology in short it was simply too
complicated and could not be
operationalized and after a year more
than a year of effort we had to abandon
the project we also have some concerns
about cost shifting as discussed um in
the case of the te um you know the cost
was born by all including low to
moderate income members however the
benefit in cost based rates is only
going to the de our participants in the
program and we were concerned that this
was unfair and at our uh at odds with
our pricing philosophy which aims to
have individual members pay for the
costs associated with those enhancements
or changes to their service uh and then
finally you know there's just the
complexity of it um you know energy
markets metering load management it's
kind of exciting for someone who like me
who deals with this every day but uh
when I step outside of the cooperative
and talk to you know friends and family
their eyes glaze over and we in fact we
find that most members really have a
hard time understanding even basic solar
interconnection requirements or
unbundled rates let alone complex
pricing like uh you know the TR in that
case and in fact most members they
simply want to know that their power is
reliable and affordable so uh I thank
you for that and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you I am a co-op member
just to make that clear to everyone does
the co-op currently use Ami meters yes
we do okay thank you
representative courtman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um it it's interesting you you
said that you actually tried to
Institute time of use rates and people
weren't taking them up um I know that
I've looked at the Unitil rates and
there's a really Stark difference
between uh off peak and on Peak is it
possible that people weren't taking up
the rates because the difference was so
severe and perhaps maybe uh making less
severe might have had allowed people to
take it up thank you for the question um
first of all the Cooperative still does
have time of use rates uh they're more
of a traditional time of use rate we
have that available for uh basic
residential members and we also have a
net metering time of day rate with on
andof Peak pricing in both directions um
but with regard to the te this was an
hourly pricing and we found this uh the
members found this to be extremely
difficult to understand and also
especially the device integration with
these uh various manufacturers with
battery storage electric vehic vehicle
to grid and then also the Billing System
impl uh imple implications uh made it
very difficult so we still do offer the
traditional time of day options we have
very little um uptake of those but they
members okay further questions
representative Harrington could you
expound a little bit when you say
traditional time of day or time of right
could you tell me what that implies sure
so uh for inance since for we have two
different programs with different hours
this work gets complex when you add more
and more programs on for our basic
residential members if they so choose
they can participate any time of day
rate um and the on peak hours are 7
o'clock in the morning until 11 o'clock
at night Monday through Friday non-
holiday there's also an electric vehicle
component if you want to subm your
electric vehicle and then off peaker all
the other hours nights and weekends and
holidays and then we have a net metering
time of day where we designed that more
recently we actually designed that right
around the same time as the te
uh we kept it though because it really
doesn't have much overhead to implement
with our current systems and that has
only a 4-Hour Peak uh from 4:00 to 8:00
Monday through Friday non holiday
because that's when most of our Peaks
typically happen transmission and also
capacity um but again you know we we
have not have much uptake in either of
those
programs representative Bernardi has a
question thank you chair so
uh when you tried this system uh one of
the things that's been uh articulated
here is that that the claim of high cost
is
because utilities are trying to do this
with their own workforces and make their
own uh it departments develop all these
systems and not using external
contractors who are fcil in these uh
activities what did uh the co-op do use
internal systems or did you kind
contract both uh so there were some
internal projects especially related to
cost unique to New Hampshire however our
um our software vender for billing and
all other systems pretty much is an the
nisc platform which is also Cooperative
that serves over 900 cooperatives so
they provided some of the functionality
and there was a lot of custom
programming involved that they had to
you okay seeing no further questions
we'll give the last word on this
back thank you uh again Michael AATA
representing ever Source energy again
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you today uh and again uh great
respect for the bill sponsor and her
goals uh and her desire to to move
forward on a number of very complicated
uh issues uh however eversource is again
uh opposed to uh this legislation um and
I'll I'll try to keep this high level
and brief I understand you uh have other
business to attend to but at its core uh
this legislation is really an attempt to
radically change how New Hampshire's
Electric utilities settle load with ISO
New England in a way that we believe
will drastically increase costs for all
customer customers with a goal to
advance the business interests of one
unregulated entity in the state who has
expressed a desire for this additional
functionality and changes to our systems
today all of New Hampshire's utilities
accurately settle load with ISO New
England we use the same process that
nearly every other utility across New
England uses this process accurately
accounts for reductions in load due to
conservation Energy Efficiency or
exports from distributed energy or the
usage or load reduction at the site of
the DG where it is offsetting the the
load and actually being used to serve
the customer where the DG is located any
reductions in load today under our load
settlement process are accounted for and
those savings if they exist are shared
with all customers including those who
are on competitive Supply and that is
allocated proportionately based upon
each suppliers share of load that they
serve there isn't some pot of money that
isn't being accounted for all savings
associated with either exports or
reductions in load are accounted for if
they reduce transmission Peaks if they
reduce capacity Peaks if they reduce the
amount of electricity that needs to be
purchased it is a accounted for and it
is shared back to customers that is a
point the bill before you today would
require different metering different
accounting for exports and create an
entirely new class of customer called
load reducers that would be entitled to
specific benefits and privileges that
presumably other customers would not be
at its Essence the bill would require
all of New Hampshire's utilities to
offer individualized variable customers
customer specific rates in order to do
this utilities as you have heard would
have to make hundreds of millions of
dollars in
Investments and change how their load
settlement processes exist today and
become outliers
in the iso New England
region that is concerning for us it
creates variability additional cost and
the potential under the bill for
inaccurate readings and inaccurate load
settlement with ISO New England and as
the entity that settles load the utility
information because we accurately settle
load today and account for reductions in
load essentially what the bill is
proposing is Shifting costs among
different customer groups there would
not be overall customer savings there
would simply be winners and losers there
would be customers who would see a
reduction in their bills or suppliers
who would see a reduction in their bills
if we were able to get the functionality
to work as intended under the bill and
there would be customers who would see
for all of
that the minimal savings because again
this is accounted for under the process
today so you're really talking about the
Delta uh between today and the future uh
again we would be spending hundreds of
millions of dollars on a regime that we
don't know whether it could would be
workable or
not uh I'll leave it there um I'm happy
to answer questions uh that the
committee may have uh I guess my final
word is these are extremely technically
complex Concepts and I would encourage
the the committee and the legislature if
they don't have a full understanding of
the implications of a piece of
legislation to defer action and not move
forward with a bill that they don't
fully know the Implement implementations
of Passage thank
you thank you appreciate that
testimony frequently when I'm trying to
evaluate complex legislation like this I
ask questions of my old pal chat
GPT and I asked chat GPT the other day
uh uh about the term load reducer and
chat GPT told me that it is not a widely
accepted or standardized Concept in
utility
regulation does that jive with your
understanding so the traditional way
that utilities or or really the standard
definition of a load
reducer is in this context is uh a
distributed generation resource that is
reducing load on site so imagine a
customer has solar instead of purchasing
electricity from uh the electric
distribution system their solar is
serving them thus the utility sees a
reduction in load and 30 around 34 of
behindth meter solar output is used in
New Hampshire today to reduce on-site
load what this bill would do is is
really radically expand that definition
to say not only are you reducing load at
the customer generator site but you're
also reducing load for the overall
system and all your your friends and
neighbors uh which doesn't take into
account the fact that that generation
Source relies upon the distribution
system in order to essentially get their
product to Market and that there is
questions seeing none okay we thank you
and we'll close the public hearing now
on House Bill 755
so that we can immediately move into a
public hearing on House Bill
761 relative to customer energy storage
and I'll call on the prime sponsor
representative Thomas Corman to explain
this legislation to us Mr chair there's
a
question yes representative parshall
than your chair V at some point could
you get the online numbers uh for people
have spend the testimony not not right
now but when it's
okay thank you
representative PL I'll ask you to work
you okay thank you Mr chairman for the
record Tom Corman I represent Grafton 15
which is Ward three of the
micropolitan city of
Lebanon and I'm here to introduce HB 761
which is about storage I actually think
we don't talk enough about storage in
this committee and I think we're going
to be talking about it more and more as
time goes
on the beauty of storage is that it
allows us to time shift generation you
can generate at one time and then make
that power that energy available at
another time so for example I have solar
panels on my house and I also have 30
kwatt hours of batteries in my
basement my solar panels are very
productive at solar noon which is not
exactly the peak time for when the power
is needed so what I'm doing is I'm using
some of that power but I'm storing most
of it in my
batteries now I can't currently take
that power that's in my batteries and
put it out onto the Grid at peak times
it would be lovely to be able to do that
but I I can't because I can't net meter
that and that's what this bill is trying
to resolve that we should be able to net
meter from
batteries Battery Technology is rapidly
changing I know that we think of the
lithium ion batteries that we have now
and we think of some of the disasters
like what just happened at Moss Landing
a few weeks ago but Battery Tech
technology is
changing and we're seeing things like
iron air batteries and if you recall a
week from today I'm going to be at the
factory in wton West Virginia that is
making iron air batteries for the 8.5
gigatt hour installation in Lincoln
Maine so we're going to be seeing that
we're seeing what's happening at
Schiller and maramax station where
battery installations are going
in there are also solid state batteries
that are coming down the pike and
they're they're becoming
real Hyundai and Honda are opening
factories to create solid state
batteries and solid state batteries just
to fill you in on that a traditional
lithium ion battery has a liquid
electrolyte solid state battery has a
solid electrolyte it has nothing to do
with solid state chips it's just a
matter of what the Electro is like and
there's actually something in between
that's also being developed with a gel
electrolyte the beauty of solid state
batteries is they're much more energy
dense than lithium ion they charge up
much quicker so you know you you think
about uh if you're driving an EV and
you've got to stop to charge and it's
going to take a while it'll take a lot
less and they're a lot less prone to the
fires that we see so when we think about
batteries don't think about batteries
today think about what batteries are
going to be so the purpose of this bill
is simply to allow for net metering for
storage so that people who have storage
can actually take that power when the
power is not needed for the grid store
it and then put it out onto the grid and
this bill just says that the uh the DOE
Department of energy should adopt rules
and the Public Utilities Commission will
approve the tariffs and issue the orders
in proceedings to allow for net metering
from
batteries um and that's really what the
spill's about okay pretty simple thank
you representative Harrington has a
question for you yeah thank you then you
for take my question well from the uh
the grid perspective I I don't think it
makes any difference whether the
electricity is coming directly from a
solar panel back out to the distribution
system when you're producing less more
than you consume or if it's going from a
solar panel into a battery and waits a
few hours then goes back out on the
distribution system it's there's no
difference that I can see is there I
actually think there is a difference so
if I'm producing a lot at solar noon and
it's not really needed at solar noon by
the grid as a whole it's not doing much
good for me to do that and and I've
heard that criticism of solar uh from
this very committee so by storing it at
my house in my batteries which by the
way might be in a car and then putting
it back out onto the Grid at a time when
it's actually needed I'm actually
providing a benefit to the
grid followup followup no I wasn't
referring so much to the time of day but
just to the physics of it as far as the
Grid's concerned if you're putting out
the same amount of electricity whether
it's it 2:00 in the afternoon or or 4:00
in the morning it's there may be a
different need but the electric physics
of it doesn't
change well I agree that the electric
physics doesn't change but the point is
that I'd be putting it out when it's
actually needed
okay additional questions representative
rolds has one thank you Mr chairman
thank you Tom for being here introduc in
the bill Al even although you spent some
time educating us on the
various battery
technologies
um there's nothing about tech Battery
Technology in this bill and so
that battery owners would be bearing all
their technological risk you know
whatever kind of battery they might have
now or procure in the future this
legislation
is
technology um neutral right technology
uh doesn't say doesn't say anything
about the technology the the owners of
the batteries would be at risk for their
choice that's right and and the reason I
I talked about the the technology
changes that we're seeing is because I
think we're going to be seeing more and
more batteries certainly with EVS but
just in general as as the technology is
improving I don't think um that I'm
going to have an iron air battery at my
house I you know these are utility scale
batteries they take a lot of area and
they're very very heavy because they're
made of iron but you know as solid state
batteries become more available and
become cheaper we I think we're going to
see more and more people adopting solid
state batteries whether it's in their
vehicles or in their homes and um I
think we'll seen more and more of a use
metering okay thank you representative
Harrington has another question just to
follow up on that uh and then you take
my question uh you think energy storage
systems is is definitive enough or is
that kind of Leave It Wide Open or are
you just relying on the uh Department of
energy to come up with a somewhat there
going to have to be some kind of a
definition because that can mean a lot
of different things to different people
do you think that would be done in the
rules rather than specified in the
legislation thank you uh yeah I I would
imagine that being done in the rules and
you know I can imagine you know you
could talk about let's say closed loop
pumped Hydro right that that's probably
what you were thinking and um yeah mean
I I wasn't really thinking that as as a
storage system and and I would leave
that up to the department and the Pu to
decide how to proceed with that
representative
migy thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for taking my question so in just
looking at the bill it appears to be
attempting
to uh illustrate in statute uh a segment
on storage that doesn't currently exist
right so the whole point of the exercise
is to let the department of energy and
the commission know what is expected of
them and also to add this portion so
that it's revealed in statute is that
correct yeah well I I wouldn't say that
it that the storage doesn't exist it's
it's that the net metering for the
storage doesn't exist so it's not
defined adequately it's it's it's just
not allowed at this point and we're
you okay seeing no further questions
I'll ask Matt Young from the doe to come
Bill thank you Mr chairman members of
the committee um for the record again
Matt Young I'm an attorney at the
department of energy um department is
neutral on this bill and just wanted to
raise a few concerns um really um I
guess just maybe structural concerns is
maybe the best way to put it and I think
I thank uh rep Corman for his testimony
um that that did help clarify some
questions that we had U with the I guess
the the uh jurisdictional concerns with
the language inserted in section two um
as the department does not have the
authority uh to regulate net metering
and we are in the process of developing
uh 900 rules as we speak um
we would be
um you know if the if the legislation
does decide to move forward we be happy
to work with uh rep Corman to sort of
address the um the jurisdictional
concerns there in section two um and in
terms
of I I I guess
another struggling for another word
besides structural another structural
concern that we had was um we do believe
that there may be some changes required
for um the net metering law 362a
uh colon 9 that would need to be um I
guess flushed out discussed um just sort
of implement the intent of this
legislation um which we' be happy to
happy to work with the legislature on
that and I guess on that note I would
just note that there is a um energy
storage task force Bill moving through
the Senate um now U so some some of
those conversations maybe U could happen
in that form as well and with that happy
to answer any questions questions for Mr
Young represent of
Harrington quick uh I I realize you talk
about some structural things that may be
addressed but from the principle of this
it sounds like the department has no
problem with allowing energy storage to
participate in net majoring so my
understanding from uh just talking to
some folks inside the department is that
there uh are con some concerns with uh
making sure kind of where the energy
comes from how it's compensated um
whether it's store or how it's stored
and then kind of sent back to the grid
uh are concerns that we do have so but I
I again I think that that would probably
just be better in a um okay in a energy
task force Forum or investigation of
sorts quick followup it sounds like
those could be addressed in the rules
process then that that that's another
well okay see you know further questions
we'll move along and I'll call on David
st& thank you first time speaking here
my name is David hemway and it is a
pleasure to be here and able to uh
testify
today um I did give a paper that is
coming out it is double-sided and there
are a couple charts on that that you may
want to see that I'll reference I'm not
going to read through that testimony and
it was provided to you earlier in email
as well my name is David hemway from
Webster New Hampshire where I'm the
chair of the select board and on the
energy committee I sit on the board of
directors for the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire as the member
representative from Webster I am an
engineer by trade and have designed and
installed the solar and battery storage
on my own home I would be happy to
answer any questions you have about data
existing programs challenges this bill
solves or anything else at the end of my
testimony I am in favor of HB 761 before
us today enabling retail customer energy
storage programs storage is an extremely
important part of both grid resiliency
and optimization as well as efficiency
load reduction rate stability and rate
reduction to set some background there
are two major places in Electric Supply
where storage is extremely impactful the
first is the many Peak demand response
programs that load reduce at peak times
I'm currently enrolled in a small
program from ever source for this in New
Hampshire where they pay up front based
on the capabilities of the batteries I
have installed to be in the program
these are set it and forget it programs
as all semi- recent systems handle this
here's an example from the application
for the storage that is on that most
other states however have rate setting
such as this bill would provide that can
enable this at more scale with smaller
payments per event allowing for longer
term value both to other rate payers and
to the battery owner by ensuring that
only when rate payers would save money
does the system pay the battery owners
the one bit I'll make sure to point out
from my written testimony is how much
this can really save according to the
iso New England in 2023 the average
real-time energy price was
$35.70 per megawatt hour but 88% of grid
level demand and response events
happened at ,000 per megawatt hour
removing however much was put out by the
storage programs at that high cost mark
from the need to be purchased at those
prices and then recharging at the lower
more average rates this becomes
especially important in New Hampshire
now as utilities become mandated to
further expose default Supply customers
to this High volatility of the real-time
Market the second thing is the duck
curve that you've probably all seen
before this is on the back of that paper
and in large part due to not having time
sensitive pricing and demand-based net
metering this is causing fixed southface
Soler as the maximum value to be
installed and you can see in the graph
from ISO New England there how this is
expected to impact the ability of Basel
load generation to function such as
nuclear this bill can help New Hampshire
fix that by tying storage into net
metering load shapes and timing can be
included incentivizing the filling of
storage during the middle of the day and
using it from Storage in the evening so
the peak curve doesn't go as high in
expensive this flattening of the curve
due to net metered load reduction has
the double benefit of keeping the top
costs lower while keeping base
generation from being as affected in
summary this bill would allow for the
competitive storage Marketplace to take
off that will enable people like me
those considering storage in the future
and those who already have storage to
make everybody's rates lower and
maintain the value of New Hampshire's
existing base generation for longer so
please vote Yes and support this bill as
ought to pass you will be supporting
grid stabilization more economical
buildout of the grid Market competition
and lower rates for all without rate
payers picking up construction costs
thank you for your time and considering
this important issue and I look forward
to your questions thank you very much
way representative Wendy Thomas thank
you Mr chair um not really a question as
much as a comment um it's your first
time testifying and you did a great job
uh explaining this thank you very much
thank you forward to any other questions
or explanations you'd
like we have two more more pink cards
here and we'd like to get them in before
we have to break
so yes we're we're all done with you
thank you I appreciate you being
cpcn and I know you asked for three
minutes but if you could do it in two
we'd appreciate
it good morning again and I will
endeavor to do it in one
um so again uh good morning everybody uh
Dena Dennis director of regulatory and
legislative affairs with the community
power Coalition and also with me is uh
Clifton
below and the community power Coalition
um supports House Bill 761 for four
reasons first um we think it provided it
provides necessary
clarification um regarding the roles and
responsibilities of the doe and the
Public Utilities Commission um just
wanted to point out that last last year
the legislature passed Senate Bill 391
which directed the department to develop
proposed rules for the interconnection
of distributed energy resources um of
which that they be aligned with National
Best Practices um including the
interstate renewable energy council's
model interconnection procedures those
model connection procedures include
storage so we think it is appropriate to
move that role from the Public Utilities
Commission over to the department um so
so that the department can include
storage as it's um in its uh proceeding
to develop Draft rules for distributed
energy resources um second uh making the
clarifications will streamline the
regulatory process create greater
transparency um for the industry and for
customers that are looking to uh adopt
energy storage um this bill will
demonstrate that uh New Hampshire is
open for business when it comes to
enabling a market for storage um third
it will enable innov by capturing
benefits of storage which include
avoiding wholesale power costs
transmission and distribution costs
helping to provide resilience greater
control to customers o and communities
over their energy
availability um and then when storage is
combined with local power generation the
benefits can be multiplied um I know as
mentioned earlier the department of
Energy's value of deer study found that
the addition of storage substantially
increased the value of distributed gener
um and that's why Section 3 is important
because it clarifies the puc has the
authority to incorporate storage as part
of net metering fourth and lastly um it
aligns with State energy policy
preference for customer choice and
Market competition and is consistent
with the principles for storage
2 and I I just wanted to help answer a
couple of questions that came up um
section one of rsa3 74h includes a
definition of energy storage so that
that's what uh the term it is defined in
statute um I think that was the main
point that's
questions looks like we don't have any
people are probably getting ready for
lunch which puts a little bit of
pressure on Sam Evans
ation take it as a challenge see if I
can do in 45 seconds uh so clean energy
New Hampshire does support this bill we
see it as a fairly straightforward
attempt to to try to once again uh move
the peanut forward on getting uh access
to some sort of Market structure in
place for energy storage I just note and
this is in my testimony the legislature
has at multiple times over the past 5
years directed uh the regulatory bodies
in in question here to develop uh or
study creating some sort of price signal
that would encourage customer cited
storage um and over the past several
years progress in that direction has
stalled there is an open investigation
that the department of energy opened in
2023 but we've seen no action in that
investigation since August of 2023 um
and uh and I will note that that
essentially we are are already allowing
batteries to receive net metan
compensation as part of the Liberty
Utilities battery storage pilot um which
has been approved by the Public
Utilities Commission and has been found
to be costeffective um and the puc in
fact ordered Liberty to include you know
further phases of that battery storage
pilot in uh in their rate case their
rate case is currently um sort of up in
the air as as many know so uh once again
further progress in that in that area
has has stalled so uh I think there's a
tremendous opportunity to use battery
storage to reduce the costs of of uh
grid infrastructure and provide rate
relief to to rate payers and this is
just another mechanism through which
such a program could be
established thank you Mr R Brown can you
say anything more about the Liberty
pilot uh y did it did it turn out to be
cost effective did it turn out to be a
useful program it did and and there is
actually uh a footnote in my written
testimony that would direct you to the
filing in which the Pu uh found it to be
cost- effective and I will note uh those
batteries were installed during the
pandemic sort of 2019 2020 20 21 time
frame and costs of battery packs have
only Fallen since then uh so I think
that that uh you know really the time is
now to figure this out and to the point
that Clifton Belo made uh you know we're
headed into a period of Rapid load
growth and having storage as as a
potential asset to try to make sure that
the grid is is able to absorb that
growth in a cost- effective manner I
think is really important that and
something that policy makers should be
really thinking
questions I'm guessing people want to go
to lunch
so uh we'll bring to a close then the
public hearing on House Bill
761 we will take a lunch break effective
until 1:15 this afternoon
and I'd ask everybody in the room to
please clear the room so that
Republicans can caucus thank you very
e
okay let's get started with the
afternoon session here of stn for
February
18th we're going to pass judgment on
five bills in an executive session and
then after that we're going to return to
public hearings for two more bills HB
759 and HB
760 so we'll begin the activity of the
afternoon by open opening a public a
executive session on HB 72 23 FN and I
the chair recognizes representative
bney I move that we judge HB
723 as ought to pass chair recognizes
representative fog I'll second there a
to pass okay it's been moved and
seconded that we adopt the motion of a
to pass for ill 723 FN chair recognizes
representative bney thank you chairman
um so I'll I'll be pretty brief um as
far as the U benefits to individual
customers and their data utilities that
have Ami are already providing portals
where users can see their or their usage
um one of the benefits that would have
come from the data platform is is
aggregated view of usage either by uh an
apartment building or municipality or
the entire State um which is a much
larger uh much smaller um um number of
of users that would benefit from that as
opposed to the rate payers um arguably
Department of energy would have been the
biggest benefactor uh and they were
neutral on the bill so uh the federal
government could have also benefited
from that and they had two opportunities
to fund this project and they chose not
to um and other than that the benefits
uh there wasn't very many benefits
listed so it's not really clear um
under what circumstances some like who
who would benefit from it and how they
would benefit was not brought up in the
you
okay additional comments on the motion
723 representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman yes um to the points that were
made I I think in the hearing where we
have limited amount of time to present
something which is basically a 5 and a
half year effort that was set in motion
by the state of New Hampshire uh uh with
cooperation from doe and the
utilities um there were handouts that
were provided to every member of this
committee one was a set of user stories
that indicated the multiple current
Public Utilities Commission cases that
would be supported by having access
to aggregated G data that can be shared
um the purpose of the model is not to
replicate any individual utilities
ability to provide downloaded
information with green button but to
create a uniform data model that can be
used across all data inputs so that we
can have a snapshot of what energy is
doing what its value is how to plan for
the future and also how to realize
savings on that system it is um maybe a
complex project to explain to people in
a short period of time but the idea that
we could do all of this
currently uh is really not borne out by
the the folks who worked on the project
I mean we also uh on the day of the
hearing I presented people with
basically a compilation from a dunsky
report that is not complete needed yet
for the State of New Hampshire that
would cover the cost benefit analysis of
whether or not to build this project we
have been um waiting for this point for
quite some time so that a decision can
be made and what passing this bill would
do is it would eliminate the ability for
us to secure the information in order to
make a reasonable decision about whether
this would be of benefit to rate payers
in New Hampshire and so on that basis I
would ask that people not vote to kill
this um in statute before we've actually
had the chance to get the utilities
which did not want to come to the table
and do this process uh before we've had
a chance to see if we can actually do
this for a you know a reasonable amount
in and get incredible benefits out
basically the data is is information and
we it is information we do not have
access to today and we will not have
access to it for a long time to come
having the individual utilities provide
that information to their customers will
never give us the capacity of having an
API of API that can serve uh all of our
energy needs because it includes all of
our energy data in one
place thanks further comments
representative Corman
thank you Mr chairman uh I'll be voting
against the motion because I'd like to
see a cost benefit analysis and we don't
know the cost yet because the RFP is
just going out we should know it by the
end of the summer we should have some
some idea of what it would cost to do
this I would much rather see this bill
and 681 because they're really uh uh
opposite points of view I'd like to see
both of them retained so that by the
Fall have an idea of what the cost is
going to be and then we can make a more
informed judgment one other thing i' I'd
add is
that we don't have the platform yet we
don't really know exactly what it's
going to be we have a description but
sometimes you need to put it in people's
hands in order for people to get it and
use it and figure out the best way to
use it and I think back to when I was in
grad school in 19
84 I read an article about this system
uh called small talk and it it mentioned
this user interface for small talk and I
had no idea what they were talking about
it was written but I had no idea what it
was talking about then a few months
later I got my hand on a Mac and I got
it so sometimes you just need to put the
system in people's hands let them figure
it out let them get comfortable with it
and let them get creative
so I would like to see
this not killed yet maybe when we know
the cost maybe we decide yeah this isn't
worth pursuing but let's get the costs
let's retain these bills and then make a
more informed
decision further
comment representative
reels thank you Mr chairman um I'll will
also be voting against uh the
motion to pass the bill to to kill the
uh pull the plug on the on the
development of the of the of the data
platform um I just feel as though it's
it's
premature
um it would it basically is saying that
this
committee and the sponsor of this bill
are substituting our
judgment about this five and a half year
effort
that got started by Act of this
legislature five and a half years
ago and then was furthered through a
proceeding at the Public Utilities
Commission and which then proceeded over
the past five and a half years through
the contributed volunteer efforts of
many people including staff from all
three utilities and subject matter
experts and legislators and doe staff
all this effort's been put into this and
just as we're on the
cusp of the RFP going
out which would give us a firm cost and
enable the cost benefit that others have
talked about we're going to pull the
plug it just doesn't make
sense in addition Mr chairman I
um praised you
and said I I appreciated your
uh when you um submitted an amendment
for your energy policy bill you
specifically included uh as an element
of New Hampshire's what would be our new
energy policy the phrase Market
transformation you know Market
transformation it's kind of an abstract
term what does that mean well for
markets to change we heard testimony on
energy data platform which would enable
Market actors to to have access to
aggregated data and analyze things would
be um an enabler of Market
transformation would contribute to
Market
transformation and um better enable the
state to achieve some of the goals that
we have been reaching for
since utility
deregulation so this is a it's an
important tool and uh of that potential
Market transformation and and I think
it's premature to pull the plug I agree
with representative Corman that we
should at least retain this bill until
we have additional information later in
the year thank you further comment
representative
Bernardi thank you Mr chair uh so
initially I was inclined to agree with
uh representative corman's thoughts on
potentially retaining this bill but then
it came to understand that there are
multiple entities working on these kinds
of programs other states are doing them
uh which we could
uh uh get use of uh as well as
commercial entities are doing this so it
in my mind became clear we do not need
to spend the money on this when there's
another Avenue to get these potential
resources in a much more simple cost
effective
manner additional comment representative
Swanson thank you Mr chair I am not
convinced of the Avail availability of
the other Alternatives that have been
mentioned I do concur with many of the
comments my colleagues had and in fact I
save you all the trouble I check them
off my list so I'm not going to go
through those I'll simply say there's no
reason to no compelling reason to tosses
capability right now while we're still
looking for data so I vote against the
OTP additional comments representative
McGee thank you Mr chair um since I'm
the only person that actually had any
involvement with this and at the
Inception I just want to say that there
are other
who are desperately trying to get a hold
of their energy data to be able to do
the kind of things that are proposed by
the Statewide energy data platform
project um and we had Texas as an early
adopter which was on one of the slides I
was going to present you the day that I
presented but we couldn't get the
technology together so I could show you
those slides so Texas was an early
adopter we learned from their mistakes
when we were designing this project um
New York also has capability there are
other states that are looking to do this
as well as we have been involved in
attempting to do this the difference is
they don't have our data our system is
designed to give us access to all of the
energy data in the state of New
Hampshire so that we can cut it up and
look at it the way that we need to look
at it in order to do whatever we need to
do and energy is complex but it's even
more complex if you can't see it you
can't see it and you can't report on it
and you can't use it for both analysis
and planning and so the capabilities
that this system could bring us are
also roughly uh derived in the benefits
list that I gave everybody from
dunky's initial look at what the state
of New Hampshire could save low midle
and high uh at 5 years out and 10 years
out and that's based on adoption so it
would be based on how well we run the
project but it has been extremely
well-run to date so I think
again it it doesn't appear that everyone
on the committee has a good sense of
what this project offers the state of
New Hampshire and so we're projecting
what we want to say about it but I I
don't think it does Justice to the
people who are actually working on the
project and so I would ask that we
consider voting down the OT TP so that
we can make another motion to retain
this
bill further
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the role on the question
723 vice sh Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no
representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman V yes
108 by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill 723 FN representative Berne
will write the M majority report will
there be a Minority Report yes Mr
chairman I'll I'll write it and
representative McGee will do the
Minority
Report okay we'll close that exec
session and now we'll open another exec
session this one on House Bill 690
directing the department of energy to
investigate the state's withdrawal from
ISO New England and other strategy
decisions that impact rate payers in
relation to New England's environmental
policy and I recognize representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman I make the
motion of ought to pass on HB 690 FN
chair recognizes representative Matson I
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of ought to
pass on House Bill 690 chair recognized
representative Summers thank you Mr
chairman so I brought this bill forward
originally and I wanted to actually you
learn more about it since this keeps
coming up and we've this way this allows
for the Department of energy to be able
to conduct investigation on the pros and
cons of not only of um possibly leaving
ISO New England but tend to learn more
about it uh the consumer Advocate
testified that he actually stated that
he was for this bill as well as he gave
us a demonstrated map of how convoluted
and complicated the iso New England
platform was we also had a the dod
stated they were neutral on it but they
were willing to investigate conduct an
investigation as far as the um public
generators who said they were against it
and they stated there were two two
different items one was that this has
already been conducted within
Connecticut and with Maine however um
with extra additional information from
our committee research we found that
while we were told that both um
processes in Maine and Connecticut were
completed and they decided not to do it
Maine actually found inadequacies in the
status quo participating in the is New
England Market with main pu found
included rising and volatile Energy
prices over dependence on natural gas
fired generation less control over
decisions less influence in Regional
decision making related to Consumer
interests and concerned that main
consumers were paying more than their
fair share of a regional cost now while
they end up finding 2 years later that
the uh the cost would be they'd be
paying a bit more compared to 78
megawatts rather than 158 Connecticut
however when they conducted it the con
Connecticut Department of energy
Environmental Protection found that the
regional wholesale electricity Market
administered by I New England created
barriers to coste effective clean energy
development
strategies and threaten reliability by
increasing Regional Reliance on natural
gas they recognized that withdrawing
participation ice and New England was an
option but that the first State's
priority would reform through new
regional market designs now Connecticut
did not stop and not did not close this
in fact they actually still have it open
the Connecticut public utilities
regulatory Authority has been directed
to evaluate whether Connecticut rate
payers benefit from Connecticut's
Reliance on the wholesale energy markets
administered by ISO New England this
investigation is taking place through
Connecticut P which is still an active
docket docket number
21515 re 03 therefore Conneticut is
still conducting investigation on this
Maine found the benefits of it but found
that it was going to be more costly
therefore I believe it is in extreme
interest of New Hampshire to do this
investigation to find out as was stated
earlier testimony we are a different
state our data is different therefore we
should investigate how New Hampshire is
affected by Isa New England Pros cons
and what the effect
is okay thank you further discussion on
this question representative
Harrington you know one of the more uh
successful campaign slogans of our time
was uh done by the governor when she
said don't Mass up New Hampshire and
that's what's happening in the electric
field Mass Massachusetts and Connecticut
you notice when uh representative
Summers was talking about the
impediments to renewable energy that
Connecticut saw back some years ago well
that's drastically changed now looking
at the iso document economic planning
for the clean energy transition issued
the end of October this year it's kind
of uh eye-opening basically the policies
of Massachusetts Connecticut and Rhode
Island will be driving what the iso does
and this is this moving to this uh zero
uh emissions which will result in a lot
of different things we're talking
thousands and thousands of offshore
windmills if indeed they get get can get
built thousands of um onshore wind uh
over 200 square miles of solar panels
This would be needed to supplement the
getting rid of all the base load uh
fossil fuels we have now specifically
natural gas but even with all that the
key factor remains is that in 2050 the
iso predicts for the moderate typical
weather conditions we will have to have
12 GW that's 12 GW five times the size
of seab Brook station of dispatchable
resources that run less than 1% of the
time otherwise we'll have outages less
than more than 1% of the time now to put
that in perspective these plants are not
going to make much money in the energy
Market because they're not going to run
very often I asked the iso how they
would make money to stay open one
suggestion was to put them in the
capacity Market they would then be
setting the price for capacity extremely
high which would be paid to every
resource in New England that cleared the
forward capacity Market this would drive
up the cost of electricity by billions
of dollars and it's being set by these
other states they're ter determining the
policy ISO was basically rolled over and
said you know Connecticut Massachusetts
account for something like 75% of the
load in New England so they were in the
driver's seat so I think it behooves us
to at least look in and investigate what
the possibilities are one possibility is
maybe we find that going with like um
getting out of the iso in the wing but
merging with Maine to form a new ISO or
mering merging with Vermont Maine would
do it but I think it's definitely worth
looking at and finding out where we're
going because right now our electric
rates are going to be driven by the
southern states and they're going to go
off the boards and we're going to be
sitting here looking pretty silly if we
didn't at least look into other
possibilities additional comment
representative Wendy
thank you Mr chair um there's a few
things I'd like to to um mention
regarding this bill uh first of all it
um it's poorly written in that it is
requesting a report but there is no end
date um and it doesn't say who gets the
report so this is just an
ongoing investigation by the doe um that
seems to have no no end to it um if you
look at the information um we could say
first of all doe also um Rec uh
suggested that this investigation would
cost $200,000 which I don't believe for
a second um the um if you look at the
report that that Maine did they did a
pretty comprehensive uh report um that
I'm I wish I could have gotten the price
on but but there is no price on that um
merging with another state to create a
new ISO my goodness I mean all I keep
hearing from you guys is about lowering
customer rates lowering customer rates
um the rates would go through the roof
if we did something like that um and
lastly to use the defense that the doe
is neutral on this bill as a
justification for passing it Forward um
is to use false logic they're neutral on
everything and in fact on our side we
take a shot every time the DOA announces
that it's neutral on a Bill thank thank
you further discussion representative
Kaplan thank you uh Mr
chair I I think that this bill uh is
basically a waste of time because it's a
act asking for an investigation that's
already been conducted by two member
states of the iso New England that yes
do have different data but actually
share uh one thing in common that is
that they have better interconnection
possibilities than we do and they both
those states have already concluded that
the you know withdrawing from the iso
New England does not make any sense uh
even though as my friend pointed out uh
there are things that can be answered in
such a study but they've already been
answered in those studies so why do we
need to you know we we just heard a
whole list of of uh of the downside of
being members of of uh being a part of
iso New England so why why do we need to
do this we've already we we already have
those results we know what they are what
I found in interesting was that
Connecticut uh found that one of the
downsides of being part of iso England
was an over Reliance on natural gas so
it seems to me that these studies will
find whatever you know whatever you put
into it is what you're going to get out
and you can lead to you can it can lead
to very very different um outcomes but
at the end of the day the bottom line is
that the cost of withdrawing from ISO
New England would always outweigh any of
the benefits and the department of
energy actually concluded that in the
public hearing they they they said in so
many words that there is no way that
they can see this study leading to a
recommendation to lead ISO England that
is not going to happen uh so wh why
waste any money at all on such a
study Vice chair Thomas thank you Mr
chairman I will be supporting this bill
because this subject has been coming up
now for several years and you know
here's an opportunity to finally put
something to paper
let doe investigate maybe by the end of
that investigation uh we'll have less
times that bills like this come forward
because maybe we'll finally settle on
just what exactly is a good or not so
good effort so let's go ahead and do the
investigation get out of the way and
let's be done with it
afterwards representative McGee thank
you Mr chairman well um Mr Vice chairman
I think that's probably the best reason
that I've heard uh for going for forward
with the bill but where I fall on it is
um I just want to know how it would work
um we are members of a regional grid and
certainly we have the option to go our
own way but as was already mentioned by
other speakers the cost of that uh would
would be I I would imagine huge uh
because we we do derive benefits from
being party to the regional Grid in our
region so um for its imperfections I I
get the feeling that this bill is more
of uh perfect being the enemy of the
good we don't like all the things that
uh that the iso imposes or that the
regional wholesale markets
include
but we don't have any idea what the
alternative would cost and I think we're
or even how it would work and so I guess
that my question is why would we want to
go on a on a sort of a wild goose chase
trying to figure that out rather than
maybe trying to solve for some of the
problems that we have with the grid
over representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman yeah I I missed the field trip
to iso's control room last time but I
have a pretty good idea of what it looks
like I saw the eversource one and I I
guess the iso one's pretty similar and I
realize you know or I think about we'd
have to build one of those and we'd have
to have all the control systems
throughout the entire State hooked into
that and I I can't imagine what the cost
of that would be and who's going to pay
for it we know who's going to pay for it
so you know I feel like yeah we could do
the study but this is asking a question
answer well I think this bill is more
more than just a study of leaving I ISO
New England this it's also a bill that
wants to investigate how the rest of the
New England
states who are sort of driving ISO
policy are going to affect New Hampshire
and whether there's anything that can be
done about
it representative Harrington articulated
those concerns very very well and I
think they're important questions that
have to be answered and the doe is in a
perfect place to ask those questions
they probably even have better questions
than we could come up with on our own so
I think supporting this uh
study is worthwhile to do
and the the the results of the study
will probably be very revealing to all
of
us any further discussion representative
Harrington
yeah I just wanted to make one point
that this the previous studies that were
mentioned in Connecticut and Maine were
done some time ago especially the one in
Maine and they both talked about a uh
High Reliance on natural gas and under
the newest Plans by ISO New England
they're talking about phasing out
natural gas other than for this I'm
assumably this 1% of the plants the 12
gaws that don't run hly at all but we
still have to pay for so what was what
was invogue what was going on with
policy-wise back then is not now and I
agree completely with the chairman one
of the things we need to be looking at
here is what's the option what happens
if we do stay in and all these policies
go in with these thousands and thousands
of offshore windmills that might not
even get built so I don't know what we
do then but I think looking at what
happens uh given this uh the iso's own
predictions going forward is something
well okay I'd like to ask the clerk to
call the role on the question of the
motion of ought to pass on House Bill
690 VI shair Thomas yes representative n
yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
scheller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas Wendy Thomas no representative
Corman no Representative rolds no
representative La relle no
representative Swanson no chairman Vose
yes
108 by a vote of 10 to8 the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass on
House Bill 690 representative Summers
will write the majority report will
there be a Minority Report yes will and
it's in your
inbox so it's representative Thomas who
was writing
the uh Minority Report okay so we're
done close the exec session on HB
690 next we'll proceed to open an exact
session on House Bill
681 establishing a
Statewide online energy a platform and
the chair recognizes representative bney
thank you chairman I move that we judge
HB 681 as inexpedient to legislate chair
recognizes representative schneller
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of itl for
House Bill 681 chair recognizes
representative bney thank you chairman
um one of the issues that the department
of energy brought up is on page two
lines 20 through 27 uh which they
understood as um the cost controls for
the project would be moved from uh the
Pu to this uh platform governing Council
um that seemed uh concerning and then uh
the other reason to itl this bill is
because we passed 723 thank
discussion representative M guess just
by way of explanation yes this bill was
was about transitioning to the
governance Council as the means of
making decisions going forward rather
than leaving an open public utilities
case forever um but it was predicated on
the fact that the project was going to
be moving towards RFB and eventually um
being built so since that is not there
anymore uh the need for the bill is
okay seeing no further comment I'll ask
the clerk to call the role on the
question of adopting the motion of itl
for HB
681 by sh Thomas yes representative n
yes representative Harrington yes
representative Bry yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee yes
representative
parall yes representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas
no representative Corman no
Representative rolds
no representative La Rochelle yes
representative Swanson
no chairman Vose yes
uh see one two three four five six seven
8 9 10 11 12 13
14 to
four okay by a vote of 14 to4 the
committee adopts the motion of itl for
HB
681 representative bne will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report um you want to do it Tom yeah go
ahead I write I'll write it okay Corman
to write a Minority
Report I need that by 7 o'clock tomorrow
morning if you could
please and with that we'll close the
exec session on House Bill
681 so that we can open an exec session
on House Bill
674 relative to nonwire Alternatives
time of use tariffs and multi-year rate
settings and the chair
recognizes representative Harrington I
move itl on 674 chair recognizes
representative Bernardi second the
motion moved and seconded that we adopt
the motion of itl for HB 674 chair
recognizes representative Harrington
yeah I think we just heard for hours on
the uh the whole bit with the time of
use and um smart meas and whether it's
best to do it by legislature or allow
the ongoing process at the Pu I think
it's better to go through the process
over there where the details can be
worked out because this is a very
detailed complicated issue so therefore
I think this uh bill is
unnecessary further
discussion representative
Kaplan yeah I uh for the very same
reasons I I would like to retain this
bill because I think that it's the
legislature's duty to uh to set things
in statute and not wait for the you know
the Pu to to lead the charge on the way
we want utilities to do the work of the
State uh and yeah I agree that you know
these are complicated issues that that
that need lots of thought and lots of
work um and this bill is intended to you
know incentivize things that we all
agree that we want the utilities to do
so um I would hope that we could retain
the bill and bring it back in September
and uh maybe make some amendments uh and
and decide how to move forward with it
at that
comment seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of the
adoption of the motion of itl on HB
674 Vice chair Thomas yes representative
ner yes representative Harrington yes
representative bney yes representative
Bernardi yes representative PL yes
representative Summers yes
representative Matson yes representative
schneller yes representative McGee no
Representative parshall no
representative Kaplan no representative
Thomas when you almost said it Wendy
Thomas
no representative Corman no
Representative
rolds no representative l roelle no
representative Swanson no chairman Bose
yes 10 eight by a vote of 10 to8 the
committee adopts the motion of itl on
House Bill
674 representative Harrington will write
the Mr chairman there may be a problem
with that once you need it because right
now my email is not working at all I
can't send out any email so I don't know
if it'll be fixed by tonight or whatever
I don't know what's causing the problem
so okay we'll take that offline will
there be a Minority
Report and it will be written by
representative Kaplan Kaplan okay thank
you when do you need that by again Mr 7
am tomorrow tomorrow
yep all right with that we'll close that
executive session and now we're down to
our last executive session of the
hcr2 declaring the development of
advanced nuclear technology nuclear
energy technology to be in the best
interest of the State of New Hampshire
and the United States and I recognize
Vice chair
Thomas thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
I motion to OTP
hcr2 CH recognizes representative N I
second the motion moved and seconded
that we adopt the motion of OTP for hcr2
chair recognizes Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr
chairman uh Mr chairman I think this
committee has heard numerous uh public
testimony uh for this bill and other
bills involving nuclear energy of how
important it is to send out a strong
message to anyone looking at this state
for possible investing into particularly
the new type of uh nuclear energy we
know that nuclear energy is a wave of
the future we need to have base loads we
know it would be good for our economy
and we know know that it would be good
to shore up uh you know Baseline type of
energy here with our generators and with
the new technology there's a lots of
opportunity so by making this resolution
and telling the world that we think it's
in the best interest of of New Hampshire
to at least explore any type of new
scale nuclear energy it is telling
everybody that we are open to that
suggestion that investors could come in
and take a look around if it meets
Market um um situation then maybe
they'll invest but it sends out a strong
message and I think for that reason we
should pass this resolution to tell
people that we are open to this new type
of nuclear energy for the benefit of all
in the
state further
comment representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um recently in
Washington there was a a massive layoff
and they laid off um many of the people
that are responsible for um monitoring
our nuclear
um industry and well not industry but
but nuclear Arsenal in in um for the
United States um I think that this bill
right now with this Administration puts
the cart before the horse and um until
we understand the importance of managing
nuclear devices on a federal level we
shouldn't even be fooling around with
them on the state level thank you
further comment
Vice chair Thomas uh thank you Mr
chairman um uh yes uh that happened
originally in reference to my good
friend to my right comment but I also
learned that they are in the process of
hiring back the nuclear workers uh in
into the field and also one thing to
remember if we pass this resolution it
will encourage more Education and
Training in into this field from which
we would need more more workers
additional comment representative
schneller thank you Mr chairman just
want to read a comment recently from uh
Jim sturos from the Pioneer Institute he
said for years Massachusetts was
recognized Nation wise Nationwide is a
magnet for Capital and talent now we are
not so we need our leaders focused on
addressing the reasons why wealth and
talent are heading for the
exits uh
they further that the study further
found that the exits and and the
destinations of those people are Florida
and New Hampshire so we are attracting
the talent and the capital that would be
necessary to fund both from a human
capital perspective and a financial
Capital perspective for a nuclear effort
so I think this is a great
resolution additional
comments representative
Corman thank you Mr
chairman I found myself really torn on
this um if if my late wife heard me
saying that I would be voting for this
she would just be shocked um 30 years
ago we were no nukes no nukes no nukes
also no tobacco and um you the fact is
technology has changed and we need to
recognize that really for all
Technologies as I spoke earlier about
batteries um I also think it's true
about offshore wind we shouldn't be
assuming that the technology that that
is out there now is the technology of
the Future No More seab Brooks are going
to be built that's not the kind of
nuclear we're talking
about um I'm going to vote for this I I
I understand representative Wendy
Thomas's concern and you know I always
have tremendous respect for anything
that she says and I understand her
concern about what's going on um at the
federal level um but I I
just can't believe that we'll have
completely unfettered
unregulated nukes everywhere that you
know it's in in in my back yard or
anything like that and you know look we
do need reliable base load that's zero
carbon that's that's great and you know
I'm concerned about the nuclear waste
issue but that's a relatively small
amount volume wise so um um I'm amazed
but I'm going to vote for this further
comments representative
lelle thank you Mr chair I think as I
look around worldwide I see countries
going back to nuclear uh France has
always had probably the majority of
their energy from nuclear and as I went
to BBC news this morning I was surprised
to find that of all countries Japan is
turning back to nuclear and they're
about to recommission a 50-year old
nuclear plant so if they can do that in
Japan with all the seismic activity
there we can certainly do it here thank
you representative
parshall thank you chair I will not be
voting for this
HCR um in part because the only
domestic uh effort to uh create a small
mod reactor was out was by nuclear out
in Utah that went Belly Up in 2023 after
a cost of 400 million in direct funding
and 1.3 36 billion in um cost uh share
uh
revenues also the the problem
of low waste is not clearly understood
uh using the same figures that were
provided by new scale there was a study
at Stanford University that um uh
concluded that because of economies of
scale because these two don't function
function in a much smaller level they
produce up to 30 times as much waste as
regular
reactors um I'm not saying that I'm to
pull my stock in one study but I'm
saying there is Con there is controversy
over this and plus I finally I'm going
to be in oppos opposition to this
because I think when we're focusing so
much on a technology that nobody is
investing in we're losing real
opportunity to invest in other
proven uh areas such as solar wind and
hydro and I think our first responsible
needs to be investing in technology or
encouraging in the investment of
Technology of that's already been proven
lower rates so I will be voting against
this
bill representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman um I I think that as we've
heard going around the
table uh we all have different
information that we like to focus on
when we talk about
nuclear um we probably aren't going to
be building large scale nuclear reactors
unless they're needed um are people
around the world building small modular
reactors they are um everyone is trying
to drive the cost down and even the
ipcc has has admitted that we can't get
to Net Zero or we can't make significant
strides without having clean Baseel load
somewhere in the mix right so it's still
a math problem that you have to solve
for how much how how many megawatts you
need uh to service your your human
population and I think that this bill um
this
resolution uh does not harm the state of
New Hampshire what it does is set out uh
uh sort of a declarative statement that
the state understands that there is
value in advanced nuclear and so I I
don't see a problem with it I I will be
voting for it um don't think it does
anything one way or another to really
open up the state of New Hampshire I
think there are other ways for us to
work with the federal government if
there were interest in doing a pilot or
that sort of thing but I don't think
nuclear is going to go away as part of
the solution and so I don't see any harm
in the
bill additional comments representative
Harrington yeah just to update there are
ongoing efforts right now people are
investing money there's been a large um
data center that's talking about make uh
merging with the Three Mile Island that
was closed and reopening that that's
that's something that's ongoing they've
got a uh a um memorandum of
understanding there's another uh two
plants in the midwest that were shut
down that now people are looking at uh
the Palisades and Dwayne Arnold in fact
I think it was I'm not sure which is
which but one of them got u a billion
dollars uh from some loan guarantee and
another billion dollars from something
else so that looks to be going forward
too and in fact on large reactors even
giving the non suuccess of the uh um two
uh last projects that were built in
Georgia two duplicate projects in North
Carolina in South Carolina were canceled
and the governor of South Carolina has
just come out and said they probably
should restart those plants so this is
not just a dorcy where nothing's going
on there's a lot of people spending a
lot of money right
now yes according to Robert Bryce there
are 44 startups in the United States
right now that are trying to develop
small modular nuclear reactors they
won't all survive but like any industry
there's going to be a lot of activity
and a lot of money
spent any further comments seeing none
I'll ask the clerk to call the role in
hcr2 Vice shair Thomas yes
representative ner yes representative
Harrington yes representative Bry yes
representative bernardy yes
representative PL yes representative
Summers yes representative Matson yes
representative schneller yes
representative McGee yes Representative
parshall no representative Kaplan yes
representative Thomas Wendy Thomas no
representative Corman yes representative
rolds yes representative l
yes representative Swanson yes chairman
Vose
yes
okay
162 by a vote of 16 to two the committee
adopts the motion of ought to pass on
HCR
2 Vice chair Thomas will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report there will um from uh
representative Wendy Thomas um however I
wasn't prepared for this so it is not in
your inbox and it will be by 7 o'
tomorrow morning great thank you very
much okay with that we're going to close
the exec session on
hcr2 and our timing is pretty good it's
now 2:01 so we can move directly into
more public hearings which we will do as
I will open a public hearing on House
FN relative to community energy
generators and I'll call to the table
representative Thomas Corman who is the
sponsor of the bill to tell us all about
it
thank you Mr chairman Tom Corman
representing Grafton 15 w three of the
lovely little city of
Lebanon this bill was actually uh
written by the community power Coalition
so I'm submitting uh I have submitted it
on their behalf uh but there are a few
things that I want to say about it and
I'm sure that um uh Mr Belo will
probably have much more to say than I
have to say
this is an update from
hb600 from last year which actually uh
we passed unanimously in committee got
through on consent and then hit a bit of
a roadblock in the Senate when the
department of energy had some concerns
removed one of the things that this bill
does is it defines a community generator
and it puts it into uh the correct place
in statute so that's nice but it
also talks about um what a community
generator is and it's just a customer
generator who is producing less than 5
megawatts and is using its excess
generation to offset the load obligation
of a municipal or County aggregation so
for example um I am not yet a customer
of Lebanon Community power I was and
then I got solar panels and I wanted to
net meter so I had to go back to default
service but I would be very happy to be
a community generator and have the
excess generation from my panels offset
the load obligation of Lebanon Community
power that would be terrific then I
could net meter which would be really
nice so what this bill does is it allows
for
Community
generators
to um actually do that type of net
metering the other thing that this bill
does is that it actually sets up uh a
beginning point for understanding how to
adjust for the line loss and I am not an
expert on line loss I will leave that to
others to talk
about I do think this is a good bill um
I think it just helps set certain things
right so with that I will attempt to
answer any questions but I have to say
people okay thank you for that bill
introduction questions for
representative
Corman I guess we don't have any
oh representative McGee so this bill
will solve your
problem of not being able to be a member
of the community power Coalition
currently as well as net metering at the
same time it would
help right because I mean there there's
still the issues of um just the billing
and all that right so this bill you know
just by Fiat doesn't solve the problem
actually I do have a question for you I
was messing with my paperwork and forgot
that I had one so the definition on line
three page one line three of community
generator is this definition essentially
saying that a community generator is the
same thing as a municipal
host no I don't think so
um I mean
I as as a a person with panels on my
house in my
garage if I'm selling or if I'm I'm
using my power to offset the load
obligation of Lebanon Community power I
don't think that makes me a municipal
generator this might be a better
question asked of Mr Belo okay further
questions seeing none thank you
is Matt Young and Mark
Tano of the New Hampshire Department of
please please correct me on the
pronunciation of your name Tas tsano yes
thank you apologies if there was a
handwriting miss out there Mr
chairman um good afternoon for the
record uh I'm Matt Young from the New
Hampshire Department of energy and with
me today is Mark Tuscano who's a
regulatory Analyst at the department of
energy the department is neutral on the
house bill 759 um did have a uh few
concerns that wanted to uh bring to the
committee's attention here today um and
in sort of looking at this bill and
studying the implications
um had a few concerns and mainly I think
was sort of just addressed in the
Chairman's question there um we had some
concerns that there was no lower limit
on the um in the definition there um
that was one of the things we've been
looking at kind of trying to figure out
what the
implications of not having that would be
um
and then something else that we were um
kind of focused on in this legislation
was the language on line 14 on page one
um in section two which inserts a
maximum rated export capacity language
um the department has a concern and
maybe feels that uh name plate capacity
may be more appropriate for that space
um but those are some of the things
we're hoping to work on the work with
the legislature on if this bill does
move
forward and I think with that we be
happy to answer any questions and Mark
Tuscano is here to answer anything that
I
can't okay questions for the doe
representative
Harrington thank you Mr chairman I think
I'm taking my question you know
sometimes we get so bogged down in all
this terminology here with Community
generator and net metering and blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah can you maybe
put it in simpler terms okay what is
going to change if this bill passes what
now and again um Cliff Mr Bel will be
able to better explain it but as I
understand is this will help offset the
load obligation right that's the intent
of this offset the load obligation of
the of some of some of the aggravation
aggregated suppliers um our initial
concerns looking at this and some of it
cleared up was on the minimum size but I
think after hearing some of the comments
today again the intent is to allow
pretty much anybody to participate as a
community generator um to help offset
that load uh but what we do have some
additional concerns on is just the
tracking and accounting of all of this
and again I think the earlier comment
was that some of those details have yet
you know will be worked out but those
were the two big things and then on with
regard to the export and I think that's
where you were going there
representative Harington um was the um
and in my case we're working on a number
of different things including
interconnection requirements so there is
there is the thing of net export
capability uh where you would in some
cases it's because that's M you maximum
amount you can export based on what your
based native load is or you have a
limiting device or system that you can
limit your export capacity and sometimes
developers on the larger systems like we
proposing that so they can minimize the
amount of cost the upgrades on a utility
that they would have to do so for
instance if you had a 1 megawatt
generator but the local distribution
system could only handle 500 kilow you
would limit it to 500 kilowatts at that
time so those are the kinds of things
that we we'd like to get a little more
clarity on as we go through this is you
know what are the implications if this
wording gets inserted
in followup followup so right now
there's no such thing as a community
generator uh not to my understanding
additional
questions saying none thank you both
appreciate
it next we'll hear from Sam Evans Brown
haire I moved up in the rotation so you
rush thank you Mr chair thank you
members of the committee uh Sam Evans
brown with clean energy New Hampshire uh
cleanery Hampshire is in favor of this
bill um similar to last year when we
heard House Bill 1600 um I'd like to
just convey what I think are some of the
the elegant uh features of the program
as envisioned here currently if you're
trying to do a
community uh scale generation project
you're we're engaged in in sort of a a a
a game of accounting where generators
build their project or have an existing
project and then they have to line up uh
what are referred to as off-takers that
are to to whose accounts are credited
for the generation that a community um
either solar or Hydro are the two
dominant the two dominant technologies
that access group net metering the New
Hampshire they receive these Bill
credits it to a certain extent um to be
glib is is a accounting fiction the
electrons go where they go uh and and
certain customers get the credit for
those electrons regardless of uh whether
or not they're actually consuming set
electrons and and we allow that
accounting fiction because we are trying
to be encouraging of this community
scale generation for many of the reasons
that I'm sure this committee has heard
me talk about in the past the unique
value of generation that is cited close
to load um that that is recognized
through the states net metering program
um however all of that rigoll of signing
up these customers of registering groups
is administrating administratively
burdensome and meaningfully does add
costs to the process of bringing these
generators online versus what is
contemplated in this bill which is to
Simply allow those generators to be seen
as as essentially a a load offset for a
community power aggregation through
which all of the members of that
aggregation would see the financial
benefits of that Community generation
coming online which um you know many of
us over uh in my neck of the woods have
have been concerned for a very long time
about who does have access to the
distributed energy Revolution that we
think that we're we're experiencing in
the US uh and right now the answer to
that is homeowners uh you know the folks
who are Savvy enough to sign themselves
up to be part of a community generator
um and it's not your regular Tom Dick
and Harry who are just regular rate
payers they're not necessarily getting
access to uh the state's net metering
program and I see this approach as being
a very elegant solution to that problem
by which all rate payers similar to when
uh utilities make investments in
distributed energy resources see the the
rate benefit of this this de Revolution
so um that is why we support this bill
certainly I think there are there are
maybe some issues to be sorted out I've
heard uh some thought about the the
language around Peak capacity I think um
you know all of that can be solved and I
would just encourage the committee to to
take a hard look at this one because we
approach thank you Sam as usual very
good testimony to the point any
questions for representative Harrington
has
one yeah just just to try to make sure
we get this straight again now other
than the maximum output uh which goes up
to less than five for Community
generator and up to one for a customer
generator are there any real differences
in in this the way they're being treated
other than the amount of Maximum output
I think the answer to that is
essentially no you know I would rely on
the folks from the community power
Coalition who brought this bill forward
to answer the more detailed questions um
but but the question of how you do the
accounting um you know I think I think
that really when we discussed this bill
last year this was essentially seen as a
clarification of something that we
thought might be already allowed under
the the municipal host definition um so
so I I think this is a fairly
incremental step and and really isn't a
huge change to the current status quo
quick followup yes what's a heat Le
combined heat and power system uh a
great question well so so typically
combin heat and power you you can have a
system that generates electricity first
and then and then the the waste heat is
used to for some you know lower heat
right exactly uh but but Heat lead is
the opposite where you have a a heat uh
a heat Le you know you have a heating
system and and any excess that you've
got can be siphoned off to to run a
small turbine typically they don't
generate terribly much I believe uh an
example of this is the um the the um the
uh the equipment that is installed down
at froling uh folks have heard from from
froling energy a number of times and
they they believe have a heat Le system
where they have um uh essentially they
they're drying chips and then with the
excess the excess they're spinning a
small turbine okay thank
you I believe there are a couple of
Sawmills up north that that use the same
thing did I hear you imply that this
could be a substitute for group net
metering uh yeah and and I would say
that uh the membership of clean enery
Hampshire you clean Hampshire memb
membersip is is quite broad but there
are a lot of solar developers that are
represented in our membership um and and
I'd say their Interest really comes from
comes from that specific uh that
specific uh Market segment that that
currently uh there's a great deal of
regulatory risk in the group net
metering program in New Hampshire um
because of the the 2040 end date and the
lack of certainty as to what will what
will be in place um when the the net
metering program is allowed to to Sunset
um and so something that is that is more
Market driven and wouldn't be subject to
the same regulatory risk is is immensely
appealing to a lot of those developers
since these are very long-lived assets
and they're trying to they're trying to
get loans so they can get their projects
built
okay seeing no further questions we'll
move along and next call
they fell on the
floor sorry about that they fell on the
floor let's hear next from Deana Dennis
of the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire
good
afternoon for the record my name is Dena
Dennis and here with me today is Clifton
below we're both with the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire um we
support House Bill 759 uh because it
provides a market-based alternative to
utility default service net metering um
in a way that offers new options for
customers and local generators um up to
5 megawatts and in a way that can lower
costs for all rate payers um this change
is needed because current law only
allows Community power programs and
competitive suppliers to do to offer net
metering programs to customers up to one
megawatts um as uh others alluded to um
just wanted to remind the committee of
its unanimous support for this policy
concept last year um and we hope that
the committee will uh take a similar
position for this year um so just a
couple of things about this bill
uh so this bill opens up new options for
competitive entities in a I'll call it a
competitively neutral way so it allows
this construct for not only Community
power aggregations which what is what
the bill did last year but it also
allows this concept to be open to um
competitive suppliers so for customers
that are served by a competitive
supplier they would also have the option
to um partake in these programs and just
underscoring that in the this way these
Community generators lower wholesale
power costs and transmission costs that
benefit all
consumers um and then lastly um in
relation to uh section I believe three
um makes an important change to the
requirements for how net meter
generation exports to the distribution
grid are settled for competitive
suppliers and Community power programs
um because the current requirements in
or the requirements and current law have
not yet been implemented this bill
provides the commission with a starting
point to determine what's called an
appropriate line loss adjustment so as
electricity is transported on the bulk
the high voltage transmission system
steps down um at substations goes down
to distribution level um there are
losses so part of the law requires the
commission to make an appropriate line
loss of termination that that law has
been on the books for almost five years
now and a a termination has not been
made um so this bill would provide a
starting point which is 50% of um 50% of
what the utilities um
report um so we think this will help
jump start the market and provide
Clarity and I believe Clifton has a few
additional comments about that
Beast um
um a couple of things one is um this the
notion that this um form of load
settlement is unusual is um not exactly
true um uh the state of Texas for
instance more than a decade ago um
created a competitive market where if a
generator was a customer of a particular
supplier that export to the grid would
be counted in their load settlement um
pretty straightforward uh more recently
in Maine Central Main power uh either
has or was proposing to um make a
similar change uh in a presentation that
they made to the metering work group of
iso New England uh back in September uh
they did explain that in Maine there's
two options for net metering uh one is a
what they called net Energy billing
credit and that uh credit uh is tracked
of the supplier re record and it is used
to offset what they otherwise have to
buy um that's sort of the notion of the
load reducer it's not load reduction is
relative to the regional transmission
grid and the bulk power supply so if
you're local and you offset local load
uh and reduce the power that comes from
the transmission grid that's load
reduction relative to the iso New
England market so in Maine both are
enabled that or the power can be sold
into ISO New England and they have or
are implementing a load settlement
system that accounts for both um but
this bill doesn't really change change
anything about the load settlement
question except to provide a starting
point in determining uh what the line
loss is and um that that's we've kind of
been around on circles on that uh
eversource keeps its line loss studies
confidential they didn't say they could
come up with a number uh we've asked a
number of engineering firms that do this
and they all sort of shrugged their
shoulders and said we we don't we don't
know how to come up with a number what
we do know is the line loss from the
high voltage transmission grid uh every
time you go through uh transformation of
the voltage you lose energy in the form
of heat and you also lose energy in the
form of heat when it travels through
wires so line loss is both line and
trans Transformer loss and uh there's a
certain amount when you step down from
the transmission grid there's less when
you put Power onto the local grid and
and um it it's offsetting the nearest
loads on the distribution grid so that's
just how that's resolved um and I would
also note that um uh to to the extent
load settlement uh needs to change there
are vendors out there who are changing
it to do precisely this kind of
accounting and one example is Ron's
Advanced settlement uh system uh that is
specifically designed to account for uh
energy in all these different ways and
uh be able to support that kind of
settlement but that that's really a
question for the commission to determine
and and I think the only other point I
wanted to make is um the maximum rated
export capacity is um that is a concept
from those model IR rules that uh the
department was asked to develop model
rules or rules for distributed energy
resources and it simply recognizes the
fact that today there are
Technologies uh including inverter based
systems smart inverters that can be
engineered to limit how much goes onto
the grid so for example you could couple
uh if you knew a place on the grid that
only has capacity for say 1.5 megawatts
you could maybe put in a solar project
that's more than that Plus Storage that
has a combined because maybe all the
power goes to the storage inverter it
can be engineered so it can be limited
to that 1.5 megawatts even if the
nominal name plate capacity is more it
just never would export more and it
might be that that is what the
distribution system can handle at that
point so it just it just updates the
language but it it's not a critical part
of the bill what's critical is how this
is different than a municipal host
because a municipal host there are no
real off-takers um it doesn't offset
anyone's individual load to the extent
it reduces load it's socialized across
all rate payers so this gives an
opportunity for uh projects particularly
in the 1 to 5 megawatt range to not be
comp that you would not qualify for any
compensation from the utility for energy
or capacity it has to come from the
community power aggregation or uh the
the competitive power supplier who's
buying that power uh in in a net
metering relationship and uh that
Surplus power so in that way it it
avoids the issue of cost shifting that
occurs now with Municipal host um and
and for the city of Lebanon we just
recently uh finished work on a one
megawatt landfill gas to energy project
and the only practical option for it was
to be uh selling its um Power to uh
Liberty through uh net metering and what
both the city would like and the
Coalition serving lebanan Community
power would like is to use that one
megawatt of power uh to offset a Lebanon
Community Po's load uh which is always
much more than that uh what it can
export to the grid so it's just it's a
it's a way it's an alternative that's
gets us out of the utility having to
provide the compensation and gets the
utility of out of having to do all this
accounting for group net metering or
situations so do you anticipate that
Community
power member communities would take
advantage of this legislation should it
pass to install up to 5 megawatts of of
u local generation
um yes I would yeah go ahead yes thank
you for the question chairman Vose um
actually the Coalition did a survey of
its membership last spring and I think
about 40 of the 60 members 60 members at
the time last year responded and there's
about 30 projects in mind that um
communities are either they have plans
or they're interested in developing or
they'd be interested in you know being
this off-taker of such a community
generator facility so we know that there
is interest
there further questions representative
Harrington yeah thank you thank you for
taking my question so it sounds like
this is giving the um the biggest change
here is it's giving someone from one to
five um one to less than 5 megaw the
option of getting out of net metering
and going to this community generator
thing where the effect of what they what
they're doing I mean you could take an
existing net metering system now that
was 4 megaw and switch it over to this
is that correct um yes yeah you could
have a group host situation where they
say because of the uncertainty as to
Future default service crises prices we
have a competitive supplier who will
give us a fixed price for a longer term
we'd rather do that contract and then
they're out of this whole issue of cost
shifting between the utility uh
compensating the net meter generation
follow up follow up so it it doesn't it
just gives another option then for this
one to five range of things rather than
net metering it basically gets you out
of the default service business or even
tie into that it's still technically
within net metering it's just that it's
no longer net metering with the utility
okay yeah I think I get it thank
you representative Kaplan has a question
thank you Mr chair this is a related
question I just wonder if you could
lines
uh okay lines 28 and 29 where it says
accounting and compensation for the
energy Supply and avoided generation
capacity value of its
output is that the same as net metering
or if it's not what's the difference
yeah that that it's referencing RSA 362
A9 Roman 2 is a part of the net metering
statute um because this would be is
being defined within the context of net
metering um and the the text of that
statute is on page two at the bottom in
testimony additional comments or
questions representative McGee thank you
Mr chairman and thank you uh Dina and
and Cliff for being here um it's coming
back to me now why we were unanimous on
hb6 00 last year and um and so I guess
my question
is
uh is enabling this allowing more
um communities to be able to actively
lower their energy costs which I think
is a goal of everybody on this
committee yes I would say the answer is
yes it's just giving um actually two
more options for
um local energy projects or existing
generators they want to sell their offut
uh their their power produced um they
now would have two other options because
right now the only option they have is
uh through default service utility
default service net metering um or they
could you know not do net metering
metering and you know participate in the
iso New England markets and
followup followup so my follow-up
question would be then would you think
that the implementation of this language
would
um increase people wanting to um enact
these kinds of projects to solve some of
their own local energy
problems yeah I do I do think that um
the New Hampshire legislature opening
the market by making this this change in
statute would cause um you know more
interest in this construct I think the
other piece to that uh though is the
interconnection que um and it's it's a
very long process and I know the
department of energy is working to
develop Draft rules um that would be you
know uniformly applied across all
utilities in the state um so that's you
know another good thing that puts us in
direction representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um first of all thank
you for being here you always do a good
job of explaining things and making it
very clear um I just want to give you
some feedback you're you're probably
never going to hear this again but I
just really appreciate that you use a
larger
you additional questions or comments
representative
Harrington um the part about the uh line
loss uh it seems kind of arbitrary that
just picked one half of the utility
published distribution system losses is
this sort of a kick in the pants to the
Pu to say come up with a number because
no one's coming up with
one yeah I mean it is arbitrary it's as
good of a guess as uh you know the
squirrel out in the tree could make um
but in the absence of action because
there hasn't been action on that um and
the law that provided this was passed
nearly 5 years ago we're just saying hey
here's probably a ballpark figure um you
know unless or until the utilities are
willing to share that data um and
provide that information to us to other
stakeholders and to the commission we
think that's a good starting
Place follow
up no followup needed okay further
questions representative
Kaplan yeah uh thank you Mr chair and
while we have you here uh my my good
friend the representative Prime sponsor
from the micro of Lebanon mentioned that
it partially solved his problem but it
didn't completely solve his problem and
that that there was still issues with
the billing so it seems like there the
these customer generators or whatever
Community generators will be paid by the
aggregator for their net metering so do
you is that billing a problem or is like
how where's the hangup on that the
billing itself is not a problem we're
we're prepared to dual Bill meaning
separately bill or credit such a
customer cu the utilities can't really
support that now and we're not asking
them to do that um uh at you know at
this scale
so we're we and I think most competitive
suppliers are perfectly capable of do
separately billing outside of the
this you know be ideal if we could use
the utility system but um it's not
critical are questions representative
McGee this is just a knit but I I think
I remember somewhere on line seven on
page two there's a uh the bolded
language yes says load servicing isn't
that supposed to be load serving entity
it is all right well I'm gonna I'm going
to mention that for you Clifton yes
thank you it's somehow it ended up as
load service then they said it was
trying to fix that to load serving
entity but it ended up at load's
servicing entity
be comedy of eror status there right
right but so we could make that change
if we were interested in having it go
into statute correctly right okay thank
you
yeah okay
noted that change is noted okay any
further questions seeing none we'll call
next on Miss Jody grimas from the
good
afternoon good afternoon uh you're not
typically used to seeing me today but my
colleague hey croll had a conflict so um
I will be here today just to give some
quick remarks from garet State hydrop
Power Association they have a concern
and it's a very specific concern on this
bill it's specifically and I think it's
already been alluded to by Mr Belo is
not critical um page one line 14 the
bill proposes to strike the fairy phrase
total Peak generating capacity and
replace it with brand new language um
that existing phrase has been
interpreted for many years to mean name
plate capacity and we believe that that
Capa that interpretation has been
working well we're not sure of any
issues with it and we're very concerned
about why that change is necessary
because we're concerned there's
unintended consequences to changing that
well-known interpreted um language for
something new and I will leave it at
that if you have questions I'll bring
them back I don't make not have the
concerns questions for Miss
grimas representative McGee thank you Mr
chairman and thank you M grimas for
taking my question so on that on that
point um total Peak generating capacity
seems pretty clear uh rated name PL
plate capacity seems to be clearly
understood maximum rated export capacity
at the point of interconn action um I I
don't think I've ever seen that language
used before but I guess the point would
be what it is the bill is trying to get
at in terms of determining I think there
was a an example given that you might
not be um you might not be qualified at
the point of interconnection to put
Power on the system that is commiserate
with the full plate capacity correct
right that's what I just heard today in
testimony I'll bring that back to the
organization but again they wanted to
bring that to your attention that
if that language isn't really
necessarily to change then maybe it
doesn't need to so I I'll Circle back
and and respond in writing and followup
well then followup can I just ask I I
understand what you're saying in terms
of having a consistent understanding um
or consistent language so that your
understanding of how this works is is is
remaining the way it's understood so
what would be the language I know
there's stricken language here are you
advocating for that stricken language or
is there some other interpretation
you're trying to get to no no other
interpretation we would just say leave
it alone like take take go back to Total
Peak generating capacity take out the
new language because we think it's not
clear and we think there's potential
unintended consequences we just want to
make sure that they're not um and again
maybe there's another way to get at the
issue that Mr Belo was trying to speak
to and so can I just ask um based on the
language that's here then if it was
total Peak generating capacity like
commisure it with the point of
interconnection I mean I'm I'm just
trying to figure out what they're trying
to get at here with the specificity
that's here we are trying to get at the
concern that we don't think we need to
change the language um I will certainly
go back to the group and ask if they
have any other suggestions or maybe talk
to Deanna and and Mr Belo um but that is
their concern is when they read this
language they went why are we doing that
that's unintended con consquences to
come and we'd like to not have that
happen thank you sure thank you any
additional questions seeing
none we will give the last word on this
legislation to Michael Lata from
eversource
good afternoon uh again Michael AATA
representing eversource energy
appreciate the opportunity to testify
before you this afternoon um we are
opposed uh to HB
759 uh a lot of the concepts contained
within this bill uh have been previously
discussed in part of earlier um uh
testimony on on earlier bills uh I would
note that several of these Concepts as
was previously discussed are part of
active adjudications
um just two or three quick areas of of
concern uh to point out uh one are uh
the changes on page two um we would have
a concern one that has been discussed
that uh simply reducing the line loss by
half of of the utility uh assumption is
is just an arbitrary uh figure um I
think that the onus of of how this is
constructed is for uh The Entity who
seeks the commission to review their net
metering proposal uh should come forth
with uh a line loss uh study to show
that there is actual data uh behind that
uh so again concerned with the arbitrary
nature of just picking a number out of
the air uh also on on that point has
been discussed um previously uh a number
of these proposals uh could
implicate uh utility uh load uh load
settlement processes Lo utility um uh
systems and so we we certainly would not
want to erode the requirement that the
Public Utilities Commission has to has a
role in reviewing uh those proposals
before they move forward uh and then
finally uh and it's it's you know
obviously this is uh there's a lot to
this language uh but as with previous
bills I I would also point point out
that uh Provisions allowing either a
community generator distributed energy
resource to assign portions of their
output to other load assets um in our
view uh and this is an act of
adjudication uh before the Public
Utilities Commission uh those wholesale
transactions are are the exclusive
jurisdiction of the federal Regulatory
Commission and so trying to construct a
state uh system to bypass uh those
wholesale transactions at the the
regional and federal level uh we do
think is is in violation of the law
happy to answer any questions that I
can okay thank you questions
representative Harrington yeah it's it
says in here the utility published
distribution system line losses so I
assuming that means there must be a
utility publish distribution value for
line loss where does that come from so
I'd be happy to go back to our team on
how they estimate the line losses and
how those are communicated okay thank
you additional questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Lata for taking my question so
when you mentioned that the jurisdiction
of the Federal Energy Regulatory
Commission is that true for inter versus
intra
state energy transactions like I thought
there was a distinction there they would
not be involved if it was interstate so
that exact question is the topic of
basically legal briefs before the Public
Utilities Commission uh in it's called
the leapa docket uh it has been ongoing
how long has that been ongoing because I
I recall this question for a really long
time in my history I I know it's been an
open question for I think well over a
year or two I I don't have the exact
number but we're at the you know
obviously procedural schedule of the
Public Utilities
thanks seeing
none that's the last pink card we have
for this bill so I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill
next we'll open a public hearing on
House Bill
760 FN this is relative to utility
default
service and I will recognize the prime
sponsor of this
legislation representative Thomas Corman
all right well thank you Mr chairman for
the record Tom Corman representing
Grafton 15 The Fabulous micropolis of
Lebanon but I represent officially only
city utilities provide default service
not everybody takes default service
there are people on community power
utilities get rates set for default
service twice a year set by the
Pu and it can happen that the actual
cost borne by the utility exceeds what
they're able to recover in those rates
that were set and and this is actually
going to
be more likely going forward because the
puc is encouraging the utilities to
purchase less of their electricity on
fixed contracts and more on the spot
markets which of course are volatile and
we've seen in fact sometimes very
extreme volatility so it could come to
pass that a
utility is not recovering its costs from
the rates that were there and therefore
needs to recover those costs
somehow currently they can actually
recover those costs through n non
bypassable charges that go to all the
utility customers regardless of whether
those customers are on default
service so I while I'm not on community
power but um chairman Vose I believe
you're in community power so um
if if you're default service rate is is
insufficient you could end up paying for
that even though you're not a default
service customer so what this bill says
pretty simply is that when those rates
or when those charges need to be
recovered for default service they're
recovered from only default service
customers so those on community power
those on on uh competitive suppliers
they had nothing to do with it and they
shouldn't be paying for it and this uh
Bill also sets a time frame for this
saying that the recovery should take no
longer than a year you can't just keep
stretching it out and really that's what
about okay thank you for that a couple
of quick questions for you are you aware
of any attempt by the utilities to uh
extract
over or under collected monies from
their entire distribution base well they
they have the ability to to bake that
into distribution rates they have the
ability to uh bake it into any of the
non- bypassable charges as far as I know
um the concern I have of course is that
with utilities relying on more volatile
markets going forward the prospect for
this happening is
increasing so this is proactive
legislation then that tries to get ahead
of something that hasn't actually
happened yet as far as I know that's
true um others who testify may have more
information okay thank you questions for
the prime
sponsor seeing none we'll move along and
thank you for allowing me to laad my
city you're welcome next we'll call to
the uh table the honorable James
G former chair of this committee as I
understand
yeah nobody's cooler than Vice chair
thank you Mr chairman thank you everyone
uh this my name is Jim G I'm a resident
of Atkinson New Hampshire and I just
handed out a real brief outline um I
shouldn't take more than three
minutes I come to this issue from a
perspect four different uh perspectives
as a former legislator I served here
from 2004 to 2012 served as as the chair
in my last
term and I'm also a member of the
residential rate payers Advisory Board
the board that advises the consumer
Advocate and I've been on that board
since I was appointed by the speaker in
2013 through
2025 and I specifically represent
residential rate payers before the OCA
so in other words all of you I speak for
you before the
OCA I'm also on the board of directors
of the community power Coalition of New
Hampshire cpcn ainson just joined last
June and we've saved I think we've saved
$270,000 through
December uh it's been a great program
and I'm also the chair of the Atkinson
energy commission which is our local
energy commission been doing that since
2004 and in those 20 years I've been
basically a one and a Hal trick pony I
believe that electric rates can go down
it's
achievable and we always want to tell
people you know the cheapest kilowatt is
the one you never use so shut off the
lights when I was chairman here we used
to shut off the side lights because said
these are useless we we don't need these
but in any case that's uh that that's
where I'm coming from and I want to
leave you with a one two three one
question you should always be be asking
on any piece of legislation how will
this impact rates when I was a
legislator and the lobbyists would come
through here I'd always say how will
this impact rates they going up or they
going down as a member of the
residential rate payers Advisory board
when Don Cree is going through some of
the Pu dockets say I'll always raise my
hand say Don what's this going to do to
electric rates are they going to go up
or down if he says they'll probably go
up I say you got to fight this done you
can't let them do this as a board of
directors of community power Coalition
uh the reason I wanted to be on the
board was to remind the
Coalition never
forget the foundational value of lower
electric rates That's The Power of cpcn
that's the foundation of cpcn and I
always like to remind him look we can
change the world but lower electric
rates is what we're about and we need to
keep doing that and then on the ainson
energy commission you know we always ask
ourselves how can we lower rates for the
town government and for people in town
and that's why we went through this
community power exercise it's been a
huge success people love it love us they
think we're rock
stars so the three questions that was
the first question how will this impact
rates one question two evils that have
been facing us since I've been a
legislator cost shifting that's evil and
subsidies are
evil because rate payers end up paying
those
costs they always end up on the left
side of the electric bill and some kind
of a hidden stranded cost somewhere we
can't let that happen and then I leave
you with three principles free market
competition Works we've seen that happen
with the community power law that
you folks amended a few years ago to
make it happen it's been an amazing
success in just a year and a half you've
you've seen what's happened rates have
gone from I paid 26 Cents a kilowatt
hour as unial customer uh not too long
ago now I'm paying less than N9 cents
right it works competition works the
power of group purchasing works
the second principle those who take
risks should pay for the risks so if
competitive suppliers if the community
power Coalition if we're going out to
hedge our power purchases and we guess
wrong then we need to pay for those
risks by drawing from our reserves in
the same way the default investor own
utilities need to do the same if they
guess wrong and they don't make enough
money they should recover that through
either their customers their customers
not everyone else or they are an
investor own utility so maybe they
should be investor owned risks but don't
take it from a
socialized assessment on all rate Pairs
and last legislative Clarity brings
regulatory
Clarity you as legislators
have the power to tell the
Pu in the competitive Supply space there
will be no cost shifting there'll be no
stranded costs associated with
losses and no socializing those losses
across people that aren't even your
power customers so I would urge you to
please vote ought to pass on House Bill
760 I even printed this on green paper
any
questions wonderful testimony thank you
very
much questions for The Honorable Mr
gy I have one oh yes sir do you think
that the
Pu has a responsibility even an
obligation to protect default service
because it is the provision or it is the
service of Last Resort short for the
provision of
yeah okay y short and sweet appreciate
it any further questions seeing none
we'll move along thank you sir thank you
very next we'll call on Alex spidel of
pu good afternoon chairman those members
of the committee thank you for having us
here this afternoon uh the Public
Utilities Commission would like to speak
in opposition to this
bill and the first piece of important
information I think there was some
hinting at it earlier but it's important
to clarify that uh with regards to the
changes that are being proposed under
part one of this bill there are actually
two definitely open and
one potentially open dockets at the
commission where we're adjudicating this
very same issue so uh eversource in
de24 d112 in the stranded cost
reconciliation charge proceeding they
actually made this proposal on their own
reflecting their practice down in
Massachusetts as a suggestion because of
the back stop or a service of Last
Resort role of default service that
these reconciliation under collections
or over collections would either be
collected from all distribution rate
payers or flowed back to distribution
rate payers as a
credit and we obliged eversource by
opening a proceeding on the basis of
their petition we haven't decided it yet
there's going to be a hearing on it in
on May the eth and testimony is going to
be filed on March 11th and thereafter
and it's also connected with their D
24046 default service proposal so that's
being adjudicated right now we haven't
decided anything at the Pu on that for
Unitil likewise in
24065 uh the Unitil company just filed a
proposal on February the 14th regarding
the same reconciliation treatment and
Unitil landed saying we think that this
may be a fair way to proceed to have it
shifted over to the distribution
consumers both as ACC credited if
there's an over collection or is a debit
if it's an under collection and in the
Liberty de
24061 March hearings that are
forthcoming uh there's expected to be
discussion on this point uh it's not
directional the company hasn't proposed
anything but there're they have an open
mind about a number of different uh
reforms that they're interested in
talking about so why is all that
relevant the commission has not yet
decided that it's just reasonable and in
the public interest to have these
charges applied to distribution
consumers the theory that's been
presented by two of the three
utilities is that uh as the service of
Last Resort it's important to protect
the financial Integrity of default
service and furthermore uh we do know at
the commission based on our
investigation data regarding our new
market-based
procurements that the upside is more
common in nearly every instance than the
downside so we've crunched some numbers
I'll give this as a general figure but
um there is volatility in the markets
but because we have proxy prices that
build in NX Futures and other expected
outcomes over the years it's hard to
beat the wholesale markets it's
impossible to beat the wholesale markets
because that's the no middleman lowest
price option so in such an instance
where the commission is working to add
more and more up to the 50% Mark those
are the proposals that are on the table
for the utilities right now compared to
say 125% about a year ago the prices
that we're offering default service
customers are lower they're all below 9
cents at the present time so moving on
to part two of the bill um this is also
of concern to the commission because it
says repeal RSA
374 DF colon 3 Roman
5df of the utility restructuring
principles regarding Universal service
are repealed so when you actually thumb
through the rsas on that there's some
good things in here under D which would
be repealed by this proposal it says the
commission should establish transition
and default service appropriate to the
particular circumstances of each
jurisdictional utility that means it's
not a one-size fitall for our three
investor owned utilities that's good to
have remain in there then there's part e
not withstanding any provision of
subparagraphs B and C as competitive
markets develop the commission may
approve alternative means of providing
transition or default Services which are
designed to minimize customer risk not
unduly harm the development of
competitive markets and mitigate against
price volatility without creating new
deferred costs if the commission
determines such means to be in the
public interest uh the commission views
that public interest standard to be very
important important and helpful and this
alternative means of providing default
service to have a good thing in our back
pocket we live in very uh uncertain
times we recognize this our regional
electricity markets are performing very
well what we worked for 15 years ago to
bring that to fruition I think folks
like Mr Belo were working 25 or 30 years
ago to bring that to fruition are
finally coming to the benefit of the New
Hampshire rape pair because of all the
work that iso's done that our local
Regulators have done firk has done and
so yes that's good but if in the future
we need to revamp default service using
alternative means based on emergency
conditions that may develop in this
world of ours that's good to not have
that removed and then finally partf
relates to renewable energy source
default service so uh that essentially
is designed to offer the utilities of
renewable default service offering if
they'd like so I would encourage the uh
committee to um vote against this
you well thank you and uh I just want to
make sure I understood what you said you
said upside was more common than
downsides does that mean that if the
utilities were to um try to recover
their costs from with a non- bypassable
charge that
they'd occasionally collect from rate
payers but more often they would give
back to rate payers yes based on the
data that I've seen uh what we developed
at the
commission the proxy prices that are
being built into the market program are
such that you would always see in 99 out
of 100 instances an over collection that
means you get a refund to the ratee
payers so that's a benefit for the ratee
payer to have it brought to the entire
ire distribution Community however again
this is information that we have
developed internally and we're looking
at but the utilities that are making
these proposals have to justify these
these positions themselves and they've
brought very um compelling arguments
there are of course compelling arguments
against and we and the commission is
very carefully examining those arguments
one of the arguments is a socialization
argument where you have two sets of rate
pairs you've got the default service
community
and then you have on the other hand the
distribution rapay Community which is
everybody one of the counter arguments
again I'm just providing information
that was presented to the commission I'm
not aining on any of this one of the
counter arguments is that well look
anyone can go back onto default service
if they're not happy with their
competitive supplier if they're not
happy with the terms of service uh one
thing that's popped up in the competitor
supplier Community some of your
constituents may have heard about this
is that you get a teaser rate and it's
kind of like a balloon mortgage all of a
sudden your rates start really going up
well up until now you've been able to
call uh Folks at the department of
energy and maybe get some of that
straighten out but in any event you're
definitely able to go back onto default
service at the first available
opportunity so default service is a safe
harbor it is uh meant to offer consumers
a sense of certainty that yes
competition is great um it's very good
to Embark upon that but the incumbent
utilities through the legislator's
enactments are offering this to enable
consumers a sense of security that no
matter what they're able to have that
six-month fix rate they're able to get
that and they know that the Public
Utilities Commission and the department
structure okay one other quick question
you mentioned some docket numbers the24
d122 is an eversource docket uh yes
24112 that's SCRC stranded cost
reconciliation charge docket and that's
under review so the the eversource
company actually came up with this on
their own and they came to the
commission they said could you please
review this proposal and we said okay
we're going to have this moved over to
to this part of the SCRC docket and
we're going to have further process so
there's interveners there's pros there's
cons all the parties are coming to the
table and they're going to be able to
develop testimony and off for that to
the commission for our consideration and
no definitive rulings have been made on
that were there docket numbers for
Unitil and Liberty uh yes the uni till
default service proposal where they made
um that request regarding reconciliation
is
24-65 the proposal was filed on February
the
14th and so what how it was structured
was uh the commission said you know
based on what ever source is doing would
you be able to assess whether it is
reasonable to make such a proposal in
your own structure and they responded in
the affirmative and they did
so okay additional questions for Mr
spidel Tony
Kaplan DAV chair and thank you Mr spidel
for coming in U you you say that the puc
has an open mind on this legislation uh
and uh an open mind I presume on the the
question about whether uh the idea
behind legislation is actually
beneficial to you know the state's
interest um but you seem to be coming
down on the side of protecting the
utilities as a safe harbor as you call
them um but I don't hear you say
anything about opening up the utility
space to Market forces which this bill
to my mind seems to be doing it seems to
be trying to F you
know you know reset the market Market
forces so that they're actually working
in a fair way
so how do you how do you reconcile those
two interests the interest for Market
reform and the interest for protecting
the utility as a as a as a default Prov
um could you be a little more specific
in terms of how you're characterizing
what I'm trying to get us across because
what I was trying to explain was that
default service is a it's offered by the
utilities not as a profit Center but
it's just a pass through the idea behind
it is that it's a service of Last Resort
that whenever the consumer wants to go
back to Homebase so to speak they can
come back to home based the default
service utilities make no profit off of
it and the commission through its orders
has encouraged the utilities to seek the
lowest price wholesale price with no
middleman to offer that benefit to the
consumers so if you look at the pricing
Trend over the the last three years is
decidedly downward now uh if you were
to talk about
competition I would say that every
competitive supplier has to figure out
the market strategy for themselves the
commission has nothing to do with that
we we don't we don't manage the
community power structure we only
register the different plans that come
through and we don't regulate the uh
competitive thirdparty poter suppliers
I mean not not to enter into a debate
but I mean I'll just try to phrase this
as a question don't you see that uh or
would you would you not agree that by
protecting the
utilities risk in this manner you you're
basically prejudicing uh competitive
suppliers well the the question hasn't
been definitively decided it's being
adjudicated right now so I I I
personally have no capability of of
protecting anyone the commission will
decide the the three Commissioners are
going to hear the
arguments and they are keenly interested
in this area and there's a lot of I
would imagine uh debate and interest in
the regulatory Community we've been
getting a lot of filings on it and I'm
sure we'll get a lot of testimony and
interesting data points to ponder but I
would say that it's a live issue at the
commission right now for this winter and
spring it hasn't been decided
definitively and perhaps if once the
commission rules if the legislature
wishes to revisit the issue that would
be another matter but um I would
recommend to the committee that give the
commission a chance to go through its
process to enable the participants and
the parties to make their arguments for
the commission to make its assessment
and perhaps to see how things
representative McGee I think I have a
question hi Mr spidel how are you very
well thank you good thanks um so I I
guess where I want to go with this is it
your testimony has brought us to in my
mind a different place than where we
started with testimony on the bill and I
understand there's quite a bit going on
um relative to stranded charge proposals
with the osaurus case and I wrote down
all the other cases that are currently
pending that deal with this question but
to get back to the original intent of
the
bill uh it it sounded to me as though
the concern was that uh Under and Over
charges would be socialized across
customers who were not necessarily on
default service right that that was one
of the things that it sought to
address
so I so the question is
uh is that something that the public
ities commission is actually about to
respond to or is there any U end in
sight for when we will have an
understanding of whether those costs
should be borne by all customers
including people who are not on default
Service uh yes there will be decisions
rendered relatively soon so Unitil has
requested that a ruling be rendered by
early April okay and in the ever
instance uh again the hearing is on May
the 8th so those are two firm timelines
that you can hang your hat on Liberty
again uh Liberty has taken an approach
with the commission where they're more
open-ended in terms of they don't make
them directional petitions but they
throw out ideas for the commission's
consideration in the default service
context uh they've been I would say in
some ways uh they've been kind of a a
Pathfinder in offering solutions to the
commission for example when the
2022 Market Panic happened happened in
Western Europe as a partly as a
consequence of events in Eastern Europe
uh Liberty's Personnel offered to the
commission uh Insight regarding what was
going on in their Affiliates in the
midwest with direct Market procurement
having been successful and also they
were warning us of the potential for
what is called a failed auction on the
fixed price side of things and in fact
they suffered a situation that initially
they found no takers for the fixed price
contracts because things were so tight
that things were tight on Wall Street
things were tight in Calgary and Houston
and all these places where they decide
these things the the Panic Abad but the
idea lived on and so uh I think the
definite directional thing for two of
the investor own utilities I would say
by the end of May you'll know what's
going on and of course there's scope for
rehearing and things like that but end
of May early June and followup followup
the last thing I'd like to understand
better is the idea of protecting the
default service providers I I think we
all agree that we want default service
to be to continue to be a back stop for
customers if they go into the supply
market and then want to retreat back or
uh they find that they're not getting
the value that they're hoping to with
the whoever they're using for their
supply and they they want to be able to
go back to a default service provider we
want that to be preserved but I I'm not
really sure
I understand the argument for how that
is in any way threatened by the fact
that there would be other competitors in
the market I wonder if you could maybe
speak to that a little bit um well to be
honest uh when in reading the language
uh there's there's not much having to do
with expanding the competitive framework
it's just uh you get rid of those three
Provisions essentially renewable energy
default Services gone alternative means
of providing default Services gone under
part two of the bill which again the
commission thinks is pretty important
given in the world in which we exist and
the first thing is is that you have the
the theory of default service that's
presented under Part
D and I took off my sticky which is
always a dangerous a dangerous angle but
uh the commission should establish
default service appropriate to the
particular circumstances of each
jurisdictional utility so it kind of it
gets rid of the language that enables
the commission to tailor things to
different companies so you have
eversource which is very big they have a
lot of Market power in terms of being
able to go out on the markets and say
hey we're serving this Billion Dollar
Plus load can we can we make a deal
that's what they do during their uh
bidding but for our smaller uh investor
owned utilities the participation space
of sellers is getting smaller for these
fixed contracts it's not as big as it
used to be and as part of that there is
a lot of what is called migration not
only to third party supply suppers but
also to uh the community aggregation
structure and that's and that's fine
that's that's okay but they're kind of
the World At Large is telling us you
know why would we bid on a fixed price
contract on a smaller and smaller piece
of the pie because you have so many
towns and cities moving off so we're
just trying TOA we're just trying to
alert the legislature that certainly
part two of the bill uh we want to
remain Nimble we want to keep those
authorities in place they've worked well
and under part one of the bill give us a
chance to adjudicate the issue the
legislature always has the capability to
revisit issues uh and has in the past
based on adjudications that might not
sit well but I would say in this
instance uh the commission has been
taking an Eagle Eye to this issue and
really is very focused on this right now
thank you that's very helpful thank you
further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for your testimony and call Matt
energy guess we've kept you busy today
huh yeah good to see everybody again
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee for the record Matt Young from
the New Hampshire Department of
energy um the uh department is um
neutral on this bill but we do Echo the
concerns of the Public Utilities
Commission uh that you just heard um
prior to me coming up here um I think
that it's important to note that this is
as as just heard sort of at length um I
won't go too much into it that this is a
uh focus of an active adjudication um
and I I mentioned this earlier but
there's quite a bit of of uh information
and back and forth that goes on in those
um those adjudications and uh that doc
it includes Reams and reams of um sworn
sworn uh statements testimony um filings
uh that would uh help maybe provide a
little more context on kind of what the
issue is here
today um and then next you know it's
it's sort of been talked about um sort
of in questions and testimony here this
uh this
afternoon um but I think what's maybe
getting lost is uh just the the first
part of the uh sub paragraph C there
that a default service should be
designed to be a safe net and chairman
Vose I think you asked one of the
speakers earlier whether the utilities
um or the commission have have a duty to
protect that um and I think that's an
important question that this uh
committee should consider in this
legislation um you know as as a safety
net um Pro as a last resort sort of
option for for everybody that's that's
um kind of very important consideration
and one of the previous um speakers they
ask the question will this raise rates
and the answer is this will raise rates
for people on default service
and with that what the department is
concerned about is a sort of default
service death spiral and what I mean by
that is as costs go up for default
Service rates and people leave default
service and go to competitive suppliers
um Community power whether towns adopt
uh the community power um program that
leaves certain customers on default
service and they can remain on default
service for any number of reasons it
could be um you know lack of
sophistication in energy markets um
inability to obtain competitive Supply
like a credit could be anything
and by that term default service death
spiral eventually it'll only be only a
few people left on that default service
and if all of these charges are to go
onto those
few that's a that's a burden that that I
think um we should be considering as as
um the other um sort of aspect that has
been discussed today that I just wanted
to touch on was sort of this idea of
default Service as a a competition um
I'm not I'm not sure that that was sort
of the intent of this safety net of uh
default service that the legislature
laid out and restructuring um the
utilities
are I guess to put it in simple terms
they're ordered to PR to prefer to
provide default service in a certain way
and they do it um it's not necessarily
a competition for them as I I believe Mr
spidal testified to it's it's just a
pass through they don't earn a profit on
this um so I think kind of framing that
that uh this competition competitive
markets of default service I think that
needs to be taken into account as
well
um I think that is all the notes I had
for today happy to answer any
seeing none thank you very
much next we'll ask Mr Michael Lata from
legislation welcome
back we've kept you busy today too
haven't we well I suppose you've all
been busy as well um thank you uh again
Michael Lata uh representing eversource
energy uh appreciate the opportunity to
testify uh ever source is is opposed to
the bill um before you today um I won't
be duplicative with a lot of the
comments that um were raised by the
Public Utilities Commission and
Department of energy uh but I did want
to highlight one or two uh two issues so
um first again uh as a base issue we
certainly agree that this is a very
active adjudication currently before the
Public Utilities Commission uh there are
technical sessions that have been held
there is a a hearing scheduled uh and so
our view is that uh the legislature
should not intervene and short circuit
that regulatory process but instead
allow the commission The Authority uh to
to make a determination based upon the
merits presented before it by the
various parties um in regards to the
utility role in providing default
Service uh so the first thing I would
say is uh as has been said utilities are
uh do not profit on the provision of
default service we are completely
agnostic as to whether our uh customers
take default service or get their energy
Supply from a third party or Community
aggregator aggregation in fact uh when
we do have a change in rates uh we
actively promote third-party options to
our customers uh as a way that they can
achieve savings whether that's through
long-term contracts available to them or
uh or different offerings in the
marketplace that the utility cannot uh
offer um as has been said the utilities
are ordered by the Public Utilities
Commission to procure default service in
a very specific manner uh in response to
the price spikes in 2022 and
2023 largely caused by the the war in
Ukraine the Public Utilities Commission
uh focused very much on uh the the
concept of a risk premium that utilities
through our default service procurements
where we would go out every six months
procure load following energy for all
default service customers at a fixed
price that the suppliers who were
responding to that were building in a
risk premium uh because they did not
want to get caught short in the market
if the market rates again spiked as they
did uh in response to the Ukraine war
the supplier would be financially harmed
so they would build in a risk premium
into the the responses they're you know
acting responsibly and protecting their
financial interest as as any company
would um so to get at that issue uh the
utilities were were directed uh by the
Public Utilities Commission and you
heard commissioner chattai speak at
length about this during the orientation
to procure a certain portion of default
service from directly from the market
term self- Supply uh but what
essentially is is making uh real-time
dayhe head uh purchases on behalf of of
our customers uh and so uh at first we
were directed to procure uh 12 a half%
uh into the marketplace uh that was the
last rate period this current rate
period uh it's 30% and uh there's talk
there's uh dire direction to go uh
potentially up to 50% so half uh in the
market how that's done is uh because
obviously the rates don't fluctuate
every day every week every month uh we
set a proxy price for what we believe uh
the market cost will be over that term
and the way that that market price uh
was set was again directed by the Public
Utilities Commission it was not
something developed by the utilities so
we have a construct where our regulator
has told us we have to make Market
purchases we have to set a market price
based upon uh their specific criteria
and so that is is how we are providing
default service today and so if the cost
of the actual procurement exceeds or is
less than that proxy market price uh at
the end of each year we reconcile that
uh and so what we have proposed and is
currently before the public utility
commission is that because in our view
all customers benefit from the provision
of default service whether they it is a
as been discussed a safety net a back
stop if customers for creditworthiness
or for another reason uh aren't able to
access thirdparty Supply default service
is there for them if a supplier is
unable to fill its obligations uh and
those customers have to come back to
default service it is there for them and
so in our view all customers do receive
a benefit of that essentially social
safety net that default service provides
and so we felt it was appropriate to
flow that over or under recovery back to
to all customers uh through a non
bypassable charge uh I do want to point
out just two other quick things um uh
with the bill one
is if you see this through to a a
possible pathetical where the utility
has been directed to make these
procurements and there is an under uh
recovery and because we have been
directed by puc order those procurements
are deemed just and reasonable and
prudent if to use the hypothetical that
the department of energy used we had a a
default service death spiral and all
customers had left default service this
bill would prohibit us from being able
to recover those prudently incurred
costs from another portion of the bill
which would create uh essentially an
illegal construct it has been found by
the United States Supreme Court that
utilities are entitled to recover
prudently incurred costs um the other
issue that I just wanted to to flag and
this is more specific is just kind of
the arbitrary nature of lines uh 12 and
13 that utilities must recover the these
over collections uh through default
Service rates over no more than one year
uh I'm not sure what the Genesis of that
language is what benefit it provides uh
but it seems to be taking a significant
amount of flexibility even if the bill
were to go forward away from the Public
Utilities Commission to make a
determination of the best way to recover
these charges to benefit customers uh
and so with that uh happy to answer any
do you have an alternative time period
to suggest or do you just think that
that should be left up to the commission
we're opposed to the bill as a as a
whole and don't think that it should
move forward but uh we do think if if it
were to move forward uh there should not
be a time period it should be left to
the commission to make that
determination thank you further
representative Mickey it's sort of a
follow on to yours it's another thought
that I'm having on the same thing which
is we're saying maybe the commission
will decide that as part of the rate
case that's uh persisting there now but
I guess my question would be what would
be the normal course of action for
recovering these types of costs would it
depend on how large they are or do you
have a regular cycle that that would go
over that's beyond a year yeah so we are
in I'll just say the the normal course
we are in a little bit of Uncharted
Territory as I I said uh this is a
relatively new development that the
utilities are being directed to um set
these proxy prices and have this
reconciliation um certainly I think it's
important not to set up a construct that
could lead to price spikes in in default
service so if there was a large uh under
collection um it may be best for
customers to allow for the the recover
of that over a longer period of time
than if there was a smaller uh underr
collection and I would note you know as
as is been um uh mentioned you know it
works both ways all if we sort of over
recovered because the proxy price was
set too high and the market prices came
in uh a bit lower all customers would
benefit from uh getting revenues
okay seeing no further questions we'll
next ask Matthew F fum fom rather of the
office of the consumer Advocate to give
us his
perspective good afternoon
welcome good afternoon Mr chairman uh
and members of the committee um yes my
name is Matthew fwom and uh I am the
assistant consumer Advocate and I hope
you'll indulge me for just 30 seconds
while I give you a little bit of my
personal history just so that I can give
you a I know a bit about what I speak um
I uh was Once Upon a Time 15ish years
ago employed as a staff attorney with
the Public Utilities Commission and
after that time spent about a decade
working for two of the state's investor
owned utilities including a large
portion of my time uh on behalf of
eversource and including through the
time that it divested its
generation so I've been doing this a bit
of time and I found my way back uh to
state service a little over a year ago
and I'm now uh the assistant consumer
Advocate with that little uh Preamble
I'll say the Office of Consumer Advocate
is is here to support uh House Bill
760 and uh for a few reasons and I'll
lay those out very quickly and also I
hope to respond to a bit of the other uh
issues I've heard this afternoon first
I'll say the the office is aligned very
much with the comments you heard uh from
representative G uh on the reasons uh
why this bill is worthy of your support
760 broadly speaking assigns costs to
those who cause them um at the end of
the day there may be over collections
there may be under collections
but yeah I have a hard time imagining
that a substantial under or over
collection is ever going to be caused by
the residential rate payers of any
utility in fact uh the docket
24112 mentioned by Mr spidel a little
bit ago has has to do with eversource's
underc collection of uh close to $7
million from its large customer class
that it's looking to socialize including
onto residential
customers now maybe socializing costs
would have been more acceptable back uh
before migration really took hold and
maybe even before Community power uh
became what it is today where largely
default service customers were the same
customers as uh those who took all nine
by passable charges but that's not the
case customers have moved on they should
be expected to pay for the cost they
do now uh you've heard I I'll address
one thing very quickly uh Mr spidel
brought up part two and the elimination
of some of the provisions of um RSA
374 F3 Roman 5 I not the language that's
added at lines uh four and five
addresses much of that uh so it's not
really going away it's just been moved
um and as for the elimination of subpart
F that has to do with resident uh with
uh renewable energy uh offerings by the
utilities um I was part of the
eversource crew that did away with
eversource's last offering in that
because nobody took them uh they were
offered by utilities for over a decade
had no customers that language is fine
eliminated um one of the things that I
most particularly wanted to address and
I'm grateful to be able to do it in this
order or in in having spoken after both
the Pu and the department of energy is
and as well as eversource is that I feel
like there's an awful lot of finger
pointing in various directions that's
not really getting us
anywhere the Pu has said that they've
established a series of proxy
prices uh that and they have directed
the utilities to procure service in line
with those proxy prices I don't know how
they've developed those proxy prices Mr
spidel has even told you that they
haven't shown them to anybody they've
developed them in
house so they're saying well we've
developed a thing utilities go and do it
and the utilities say okay we've done a
thing we were told to do and everybody
is saying so we've just done what we
were told to do and if there's a bunch
of money that is left out there to be
dealt with that falls to the customers
to deal with regardless of whose fault
it is whose decision it was how those
prices came to be what they are and
doesn't make a lot of sense to
me as I said at the outset customers
should be expected to pay for the cost
they cause residential customers are by
and large not the cause of these uh
costs and they shouldn't be expected to
Bear them
uh and finally I guess I'll get to the
issue of uh the potential for a death
spiral so we'd heard you've heard
testimony this afternoon that uh I
believe it was 99 times out of a 100 it
would be an over collection to be
returned uh rather than under collection
to be further collected from customers
if that's the case then I don't think
there should be any concern about a
death spiral there'll always be extra
money but to the extent that there is a
concern about a death spiral there's
nothing about this legislation that I
can tell that removes the ability of the
Pu to further
augment how it is that utilities procure
and provide default service
if they're seeing that they're
developing large under collections they
can deal with that the utilities can
improve their forecasting and improve
their rate setting there are ways to
deal with these issues that don't have
to put costs on residential
consumers so with that I think that's
all I had and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you for that testimony
fwom well seeing none want to thank you
yes I did a good job thank you I'll call
uh yes you did a very good job so I'll
call next on David Greer from
Constellation
Energy welcome haven't seen you in a
gosh I don't feel that old but I'm
seeming that old so uh thank you
committee for having me uh my name is
David career I am with
constellation um a lot of what's been
said already in support of this bill I
should say we support the bill uh we
Echo those comments I do want to touch
on just couple a couple of things
from our perspective one is the matter
of these underc collections or overc
collections being put on non- bypassable
charges uh obviously as a competitive
supplier that means our customers are
going to unfairly pay what are
essentially Supply charges even though
they are getting their supply from us
and not from default service um true it
it may be possible that they would get
those um the benefits if the prices are
actually decreased or below what that
proxy price is um but we think what's
more likely than that is that there's
going to be swings in both directions so
sometimes they'll be benefiting
sometimes they won't be uh it leads to
customer confusion and it's not great
the whole reason you pick a competitive
supplier is to not pay the default
service
price I do want to add that from our
perspective we actually would like to
see this bill go a little bit further
um the the Crux of this bill is to um
prevent those uh those reconciliations
from being on the nine bypassable
charges um we think this issue in itself
would actually be reduced if we
prevented the current plan of
procuring um default Supply on the
wholesale or not the I'm sorry the um
day ahead and um realtime markets run by
Isa New England the problem here is that
default Service as many even the Pu
admitted this is supposed to be
of Last Resort and so by that nature you
would like that to be a stable price
that is a reasonable price and then
people can shop around for a different
price if they don't like the default
service by purchasing on the wholesale
Market what you're doing is basically
introducing a variable rate and sure for
the last year wholesale um those markets
have been relatively inexpensive largely
due because natural gas prices have been
decreasing but a country invades another
country and natural gas prices increase
all of a sudden the rate payers pay all
of that whereas under the current system
suppliers are taking that risk so if
there is I mean lack for better of a
term if there's an underc collection
it's us who has to bear that cost it's
not the
rayer and so I just wanted to also kind
of clarify that if if this bill passes
and the pu's plan or um proposal of
procuring more and more on the iso New
England markets comes to fruition you're
actually going to see large swings in
that price of default service because
they have to recover that those costs
from somewhere or give credit to those
costs from somewhere so if they under
collect massively and they have to put
those costs into the supply portion of
the bill you're going to create
essentially an
artificial uh Supply price that isn't
reflective of what the New England
markets are actually uh showing and so
then that would cause a really high
default service price and you get Mass
migration off of default service and
then in the next 6 months well now
they've undercollected and so it's
really low and then everyone leaves
their competitive supplier back to
default service and this makes it
extremely hard to hedge prices and it
ends up costing everyone more money as
those hedging um risk premiums are
increased to account for that type of
migration uh I think with that I'll
leave it alone and see if there's any
me okay any questions representative
McGee I would like to know why every
single presenter has brought us more and
different
information so your points are very well
taken that um that it is about how uh
how this is going to affect the market
as a whole and you said that you're that
constellation is in support of the bill
I'm assuming for the support for
competitive markets that it would bring
to the suppliers that are really trying
to um create that competition which
helps to be a hedge and drive prices
down but uh to your point about what
might happen in a bit of a you know uh
not a roller coaster but sort of a back
and forth
seesaw uh within the market for under
and overcharges affecting the perceived
default service rate uh as fluctuating
significantly I'm sure that's a concern
as well for the utilities and the and
the Public Utilities Commission so in
your assessment of this and you're
falling down on the side of supporting
the bill why do you think that passing
this legislation would assist the market
more than it would
harm uh the concerns that have been
raised already this this this afternoon
yeah that's a great question um and in
the interest time I it is in my written
testimony but we did have a couple of
suggestions for improvements what we
believe are improvements of the bill uh
the first one which I want to address is
uh
online three of the bill it says uh
which really repeats language that's
already in existing law and then adds
some things which I'll get to it says
default service should be designed to
provide a safety net and then it says um
and it kind of gives the bill adds some
language to kind of clarify the purpose
of default service and how it should be
designed to minimize customer risk not
unduly harm the development of
competitive markets and mitigate against
price volatility our suggestion is to
take the word should there in line three
and make that a shall so it is a
requirement for default service to
minimize customer risk not unduly harm
the development of competitive markets
and mitigate against price volatility if
that's a requirement then procuring on
the iso New England markets would not
really be available because it fails all
three of those um it would only
introduce volatility and it would not
minimize customer it places risk on
markets was that number one or was that
all you had to say sorry um and then our
second suggestion um was just down in uh
line nine where they have added um some
language for uh default Service uh the
the prudently incl uh curred costs
arising from um securing default service
for purchase of power capacity antier
Services we would add operational cost
to that so any cost associated with
procuring default service itself um and
then just add the word uh bypassable in
line I want to see where it is uh sorry
uh line 10 so it' be the uh bypassable
default service charges just to really
make clear that the um any cost aod
associated with uh procuring supply for
their default service customers would
Bill yes so would having it in the
supply portion of the bill then make it
easier for people to
ascertain the the accurate Supply costs
is that the reason that it would be
beneficial to have it that
way if you're talking about both of
those uh changes that we suggest at the
same time yes I think what this bill
would do already is force the um
reconciliations to be in the supply
portion because they can't be in the
non- bypassable portion according to
this uh and so that's where the issue
comes where you're going to have kind of
a false price if you're procuring on
wholesale markets using a proxy price
and then have to reconcile that in the
next six-month period that cons ilation
has to go somewhere and if it could only
legally go on the supply part that's
where it's going to start causing
massive swings one way or the other but
both of our suggestions taken together
yes that would then give an accurate uh
depiction of what it actually costs to
supply that customer as opposed to
delivery charges which is the desire I
would assume correct yes because then we
um when we give you a supply price that
includes all of our operational costs um
that's the cost to generate the
electricity procure electricity the rcks
everything and so this would just make
sure that all stays um Apples to Apples
when you're comparing your prices thank
you that's great yep further
questions seeing none thank you very
much good to see you
again cpcn is up next Dena Dennis and
thanks very much good afternoon thank
you for having me back again for the
record I'm Dena Dennis and with me this
afternoon is uh Henry
heren director of member services
director of member services we're both
with Community power Coalition of New
Hampshire um the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire um supports
House Bill 760 because it protects the
continued viability of New Hampshire's
competitive Supply Market um by ensuring
that customers of community power and
competitive Supply are not forced to
subsidize Utility Supply rates um you've
heard a number of um pieces of
information uh from folks today so um I
want to touch on a couple of things and
then also um maybe respond to a few
things that were said um I think that uh
to address the issue that um this
committee and the legislature should
wait to act because there's active
adjudication I would respectfully
disagree with that the legislature
grants the authority of the commission
and of the department and they can take
it you all can take it away at any time
so I would encourage you to not wait and
to act before this possibly happens and
customers end up having to pay for costs
that they they did not
incur um I'd also like to address the um
the eversource proposal in pu doet de24
d112 um that's seeking cost recovery of
a
6.5 I think it's now up to about $6.9
million in an underc collection from
prior periods from the large customer
group um something that we learned
relatively recently um at a technical
session in that case um and this is also
included on page three of my testimony
as a footnote is that um 4.3 at least
4.3 million of that um happened before
Community power aggregation programs
launched um and one of the things that
eversource has said is that uh that that
6 and a half million under collection
was largely attributed to community
power aggregation when that is actually
not not the
case um and then kind of going to the
proxy price and the forecasting
methodologies you know you hear from the
Pu and they're telling you the proxy
price is likely going to result in an
upside and then you hear the doe and
they think it's likely going to raise
rates so which is it which is it going
to be and I think that's the point it's
a flip of a coin forecasts are always
imperfect and you don't know what what
is going to come of it um and that's why
there's risk management
uh strategies that you can take um but
we think that uh utilities may be
understating electricity costs in their
price forecasts um and as a result
Supply rates have been anti-competitive
priced underneath what competitive
suppliers including Community power
Coalition anticipate the cost of service
will be um and again just want to
underscore that artificially low Utility
Supply rates will stop the growth of New
Hampshire's competitive market in its
tracks um and I'll just point out that
um this current rate period that we're
in starting February 1st um CBC and had
to actually increase our rates at the
end of January um and part of that was
due to a um an agreement that we had
with a local generator that did not pan
out and you know we had to um adjust
some of our hedging strategy and and
prices came in a little bit higher um
but as a result of where we landed we
are having to pause the launch of 12
Community power aggregation programs
this spring so those are all communities
that have gone through the arduous
process um of working through their Town
energy committee and select boards uh
getting this a lot of them were going to
be going to town meeting next month and
now they're putting that on hold so this
is a big deal for us this is a big deal
for other competitive suppliers and we
can't let um we can't let this precedent
uh be set
um so again passing House Bill 760 will
demonstrate the legislature's commitment
to the goals of the restructuring act
that greater customer choice and Market
competition are the preferred means to
pursue efficiency and cost savings and
protect competitive Supply customers
from being penalized and forced to
subsidize the mistakes of the Monopoly
so thank you for your
time and thank you for your
information questions for the community
power
Coalition seeing none we'll move
along and next we'll call on Howard KET
thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like to
introduce myself um I'm Howard khed I'm
from Ryan New Hampshire I'm a co-chair
of the energy committee and we were in
the first round of towns that adopted
CPC and as our
supplier of choice so um I I guess the
key points I want to stress to kind of
go after uh
what's in my heart is that presently I
feel as if utilities have an unfair
advantage in How To Source Supply as a
result of that it's going to be
non-competitive for anybody who's not a
utility to be a supplier and that's
really what it comes down to uh we we
saw what
happened uh over recent years where in
since we adopted CPC andh as our
supplier of
choice and for a small town of Ry that
is a huge huge number at the same
time uh we have seen double- digigit
increases in
taxation so it puts even more emphasis
on saving money and anything that's
anti-competitive just works in the wrong
direction case of overc collections I I
view that as is like tax returns it's
nice to get a little extra money at the
end of the year in April May whenever
you get your tax
return rather which would reduce future
rates if that was the case and rather
than to pay up
front and then share those proceeds with
everybody it just doesn't seem right and
um you know Ju Just in summation uh New
Hampshire has historically High rates
for electricity as you look across the
country this potentially limits our
state to prosper as we know there's an
ever increasing demand for electricity
in all of what we do whether it's
manufacturing AI technology
computerization uh there's an expansion
in electrification for
heating and lastly we shouldn't forget
electric vehicles so there's more and
more electric demand as we go forward we
need to get this right we need to have
it competitive for
all and um that's why I urge you to
support H Bill 760 to preserve
competitive electric suppliers for all
in the state of New
Hampshire I thank you for the
opportunity to share my
comments well we thank you for bringing
them to us all the way from Ry thank you
K representative McGee I guess I'll just
ask when did you start with the
community power Coalition that you've
realized in March that much savings was
what did you say well it was really uh
in March is when we kicked off but April
of just under two years ago so we were
in the first wave of
towns uh to endorse as CPC andh as our
supplier thank you and I believe I saw
you submitted online testimony right I
received something I did not but I urged
our select board to that consider
you okay seeing no further questions
thank you Mr KET appreciate you being
here thank you we'll give the last word
on this legislation to Cliff
samat of exiter New
Hampshire representing the exitor energy
committee
thank you chairman boss and members of
the committee it's a heavy burden to
have the last word I guess uh but there
have been a lot of words um and I've
been here for a while this afternoon and
I realized that I may be a little over
my depth here um with the excellent
testimony that's been made um I
represent the energy uh the exitor
energy committee I'm the chairman of
that uh committee and um writing and
here to express our strong support for
this
bill um as we see it it sort of uh
clarifies what the limited purpose of
the default service is supposed to
be and and it would prohibit that cost
shifting that has been you know
discussed and described earlier in this
uh in this um
hearing um seems to to us that it makes
some common sense straightforward
changes in the language um of the
statute
um especially when it comes to how uh
default service is to be
procured um our sense is that the recent
changes at the
puc um directing uh this change in
procurement that would introduce um
wholesale Market components to that um
comes with quite a lot of
risk and as uh representative G said so
well at the beginning of this hearing
that that risk in our opinion should
rest
with um the people who are either
benefiting or being harmed by that
risk um we presume that the change U
from the Pu is
is being recommended being proposed to
um avoid that um risk premium that uh Mr
Lata referred to um and that's fine um
but what's not fine is um attributing
that risk to all to all customers that
sort of violates that principle that the
the risks should lie with um those um
causing
it um one further concern that we have
is that um this setup that um allows the
risk to be um socialized to be spread
sort of creates
a um an incentive to um underestimate
the cost of the of the default
service and when sort of moral hazard
territory and I think that um that's
something that is just not a good idea
and and not necessary we think that as
the cpcn just said that would have the
effect of undermining the viability of
community
power and as with Ry um exitor was in
the first um group of communities that
uh that started Community power with
cpcn and we have seen similar benefits
really kind of startling
benefits um in our time with
cpcn we've seen a a net savings for our
customers of $1.3
million average of $400 per customer
over um that two and a half year
period um it's been a win-win for us and
we would hate to see anything
happen uh because of pu policy or
otherwise that would undermine it
undermine the viability of it and so we
would urge you to support this Bill
thank
you okay thank
you any questions for Mr
s seeing none that's the last pink card
I have so we're going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 760
FN and before we leave for the day I
just want to let everybody know where we
stand
as uh next week of course will be a
vacation week a week off we won't be
meeting at all and uh so we won't be
back here until March the
3 and as it stands right now on March
the 3 we will need to have an executive
session on four bills that are early
bills that need to be to the clerk by
March 5th those are hb2
219 HB
567 HB
9696 and HB
764 so we will definitely have an exec
session on Monday March
3rd in addition to that as I look
through the list of bills I see that we
only have three
bills remaining that need a public
hearing so that same day Monday March
3rd we will have public hearings on the
us Tuesday we very likely we'll meet
again to have exec session because at
that point we will have heard all the
bills and so we probably need to have
some work sessions and exec sessions to
figure out what to do with the rest of
the
bills so that is the tentative plan I
hope you all enjoy your week off next
week and and we'll see you Thursday in
session thank you everybody excuse me
chair one minute chair uh yes
representative PL yes you asked for the
yes the numbers please give them to us
thank you thank you the blue sheet for
692 Pro for in favor none
opposed
opposed HB
755 the blue sheet six in favor one
oppose online 98 in favor one
opposed HB
761 blue sheet two in favor none
opposed
online 106
in favor one
opposed House Bill
759 blue sheet three in favor none
opposed online 103 in favor one a post
and the final HB
760 blue sheet two in favor one opposed
online
119 in favor three oppos and thank you
chair okay thank you representative blog
now we're officially done so thank you